A little pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
Oh my god, where am I?
Oh, okay.
Sorry, immersion break.
Guys, oh, I have a problem.
Oh my god.
I know, I do.
I have a problem.
Guys, no, you don't understand.
I literally need two wins and I'll be back.
I...
I don't know how to do this.
If I didn't queue the last game, if I didn't queue the last game.
I wouldn't be streaming God of War right now.
But you don't understand, it's been a long night.
It's been a long...
I got my gamer subs ready.
You guys don't understand.
I need my GM one back.
I have a problem.
Guys, it will be over on January 10th.
Guys, in January 10th, this will all be over, I swear to God.
Chat, in January 10th.
It'll all be over and I will not have this fucked up obsession.
I swear to God Just give me one and a half more weeks guys.
The season ends on January 10th I just need one and a half more weeks guys It'll be all over It'll be all over It'll be all over This I just I just the moment I get GM money back we're gonna swap the God of War I swear to God.
I swear.
I won't lie to you.
I swear Please believe me
We're almost we're almost guys, please don't curse me I've actually no, please guys Look at the time I started
I started here Look at the time I started and look at the time it is now
I cancelled the party for this guys It's not healthy, no I do I I know I swear on the 10th This is what I meant you guys are wondering how the fuck did she became apex predator and hit top 500 overwatch that many times This is a problem This is how I if I wasn't a streamer I would have just been doing this the whole day
You know change when you lock in for a stream now you made me look like a fool Thank you for the super chat.
It's gonna be God of War!
It's going to be God of Wars later.
We just gotta be lucky.
I got a fucking squirrel girl one trick four games in a row.
This fucker!
Um, okay, they did, they are SVP, but we were playing against three tanks.
Like, this, this fucker has been, we've been having them four games in a row!
We won first, but I don't know if they were actually good, or like she was there.
I can't tell.
I can't tell if she was actually good or she was just there, mooching off.
I couldn't tell.
But then we, I, I'm avoiding her.
I'm fucking avoiding avoiding this.
I cannot have a squirrel girl.
I don't even know.
Um, Doug, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you.
It has almost been a year of catching your streams and I get to enjoy one on my birthday!
Your motivation is contagious and the dragon coming is amazing.
Happy to be a part of it.
Keep being you, Dougie, because you inspire all of us.
Thank you, the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Doug.
Yeah!
Guys, I swear to God, we will have got a war today.
I just, I just need two games, guys.
I just, um, just need two games and then everything, I mean, maybe I could ask another guy to join us in a three stack.
How good has he been?
Okay, he's been in a tournament custom game.
Oh my God, he has been fucking, I don't know, I'm not, I don't want fucking, I'm worried about having him here because, like, I don't want to lose.
We will play God of War today.
I promise you.
I promise you we will play.
Okay, let me, let me, I swear, we will, I just, I just need two games.
Get back, GM1, please.
And then God of War.
Alright, there we go.
Okay.
There we go.
I don't know where to put this text, like, here.
We'll put it right here.
I fucking, I don't know.
We'll put it right here next to the, next to the chat.
Okay.
And then God of War.
I swear, guys, I...
God of War, bros, skip to January 11th.
I'm a time traveler.
Thank you for the super fan for a super chat.
Good on.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
It's gonna be different.
Also, I realized that, I don't know why, oh my gosh, I shouldn't even have put my overlay here because that's where, like, you can see the kill feed.
But that's alright.
You don't need to see the kill feed.
You don't need to see the kill... I told Mac, I told Abrelated that, like, the Q won without me first, so, like, I hope he's doing okay in his um, in his game.
Okay, no, they lost.
Okay.
Wait, no, they won.
He played support and they won.
Let's fucking go.
I wasn't there for that win.
Fucking, that sucks.
Oh my god, that could've been my one win.
I would've just needed one more win after that.
I would've just needed one more win after that, and then...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's fine.
Everything is okay, guys.
Everything is okay.
I am requesting to join, and then maybe I'll get a I'll get...
He has declined.
Hello?
Oh, wait, he's in...
Um...
I'm R.
Oh my god, stop the Q, you fucker.
Stop the Q.
Okay.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, he stopped the Q.
I was like, decline!
No, I changed my stream.
And he's like, I gotta do my stream.
I'm doing a different thing.
And he's like, oh, you have time for one more.
No.
I have a problem.
And he's dead.
I swear.
Oh my god, it'll be fine.
Oh no, I totally understand.
Oh my god.
Please, guys, we just need...
We just need one...
We just need two wins.
We just need...
Oh my god.
Guys, after two wins, after two wins, we will get GM1.
Guys, I...
Technically, technically, Thor is here.
So technically, it's God of War.
We have Thor.
We have Thor on our team.
It's technically...
It's technically God of War.
I'm not judging.
Oh my god, wait, what?
Then why the fuck did she pick Luna?
Like the moon.
Alright, that's fine.
That's fine.
I got my gamer subs ready.
And, oh my god, it's gonna be okay, guys.
It's gonna...
No!
I can't do it!
Guys, look, there's Thor!
There he is!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there he is.
There he is.
There's our boy Thor.
Oh my god, there he is.
I would cry.
I know, I would...
I've been playing since three in the morning.
I had a six game last week.
Did I gain everything back?
I've almost gained everything back.
I will actually...
Oh fuck me, I will explode.
I just need it back, guys.
Why do I have 168 ping?
What the fuck is wrong?
What is...
No way!
What the fuck?
There's no way.
There's no way that this happens to me on...
There's no way I'm actually getting DDoS right now.
There's actually no way I'm getting DDoS.
Yeah, I'm bad.
Someone ban Allen.
Someone, you're bad for a day, Allen.
You're actually bad for the day for this.
Literally...
Where's my boss?
Ban him for a fucking day.
Everything would have been fine.
Allen.
Everything.
He actually gets bad for a day.
I'm fucking...
Oh my god, I can't.
I... Oh my god.
I'm actually... I'm gonna fucking freak out.
Oh my god, the server's better.
The server's finally okay after all the shit we just been through.
That's actually crazy.
Oh my...
You're still getting banned for a day.
That was...
That was fucking terrible.
I'm so sad.
No, you are...
You are still getting banned for the day.
The fact that that was my fucking first game...
Yeah, no.
I hope... I hope you learn your fucking lesson.
Oh my god.
That was fucking... Oh my god.
God bless you.
Oh my god.
I thought it was me.
I thought it was because I was streaming.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
The game volume must be really fucking loud.
I'm so sorry.
I forgot to change my game volume.
I went straight in.
I fucking went straight into this game.
I'm so sorry that the volume is so fucking loud.
I just went straight into it.
I was so fucking... I was ready.
This is God of War.
Look, there's... Oh wait, that's Magneto.
The enemy team.
The enemy team has Thor.
Just like God of War.
The enemy is Thor.
Guys, look at that.
Look at that.
It's just like it.
Okay.
That's right.
Also, remember to unban him after 24 hours.
Just remember to unban him after 24 hours, guys.
No, you're not.
By the way, the new Lunatech is that you bind your scroll wheel.
You're actually dead though.
Oh my god!
It's a bind scroll wheel to your ult, so it goes zoom, zoom, zoom.
It's the newest tech.
Newest Lunatech.
Don't worry, I got you.
There we go.
Alright.
Everything is fine.
You will get banned.
You will get banned if the next game is fucked up.
I swear to god.
If the next game was just like what happened with the...
Well, no!
No, we gotta set an example.
We have to set an example, Silent.
We banned him.
He put the cursor raw and I was in a 200 ping server.
I fixed the audio.
24 hour ban just for Alan.
Cause like right after I...
Oh my god.
That's fucking right.
He said it.
You gotta learn from your fucking mistakes.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
This is fine.
This is fucking fine.
I'm okay.
Right after...
Oh my god, I'm so okay.
Oh my god, he's fucking dead.
Oh, but they're all... It's fine.
We won this.
Someone's enjoying themselves a little too much.
Alright.
Whoops.
I should've been...
We're down to rams this.
Alright.
This is fine.
This is so fine.
This is so... We're so okay.
I fucking love Marvel Rises.
Oh my god, I love Marvel Rises so much.
I have a problem and I don't know what to do.
I don't know how to fix Ezreal.
You can't fix me!
No!
Oh my god, you can't fix me!
You can't fix me!
Goodbye!
Oh my god, I did it.
I'm so fucking good at this game!
Why are you so scared of him?
I gotta leave.
Oh my god, I'm sorry, Shane.
I baited the shit out of you, Shane.
I actually baited you so fucking hard.
I baited Shane so hard!
Shane, thanks for taking that for me, Shane.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks, Shane!
Good job, Shane!
Shane!
You did what I needed you to do!
How the fuck?
Oh.
I don't know.
Okay, Magnia, you gotta stay up there.
Let's do this again!
Let's fucking go!
Woo!
Ah, our DPS is so dead though.
Oh, wait, he lived!
Oh, I thought I could freeze him again.
You know what?
Fuck these guys.
Oh, wait, there's a turret right there.
There we go.
Oh, shit!
I'm still alive!
Oh my god!
How many times I beat you up?
Oh, where are you?
Oh my god, fuck you, slap you too!
Okay, there we go.
Alright, nice.
One more game.
I froze that guy like five times.
I'm...
Don't worry!
I just need one more game, and then we're back and gone.
It's just a little detour.
Thor was there, technically.
He was there, guys.
He was there.
Guys, Thor was there for that game, so technically, it's like, it's like God of War.
Lord Kurosu, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
Because the Curse of Ra isn't enough to combat this level of addiction, I cast Curse of Ra.
Okay!
Alright, if the next game I get... If I next game I lose, we're gonna have another ban.
Every curse you put on me and I lose, you're a 24 hour... You're going to baby jail.
You're going to fucking baby jail.
Akasupa, thank you, thank you.
You think... I am not joking.
I will fucking put...
I will personally... No, actually no, you would like that.
I'll make sure my mods put you in baby jail.
I won't even fucking do it myself.
Please, we're almost there.
We're almost there.
This is it.
This is the game.
Oh, my mods are so happy.
They're like, oh my god, we can finally ban somebody.
Oh my god.
No, no.
Guys, guys, it's... We'll be there.
Well, this is...
Guys, if we have no curses, this will be the game.
Guys, this will be it.
It will be fine.
Come on, please.
Someone's not loaded in.
Who is not loaded?
Everybody's loaded in.
What are we waiting for?
JL, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Look at the bright side, Dragoons.
We're going to get official...
My whole rival's at this thing.
Thank you, the Akasupa.
Thank you.
I don't have a problem.
I have a fucking problem.
No!
There's no way.
No, pick Adam.
Pick Adam, Chunky.
Oh my god, Adam.
No, you gotta... You please pick Adam.
I'm gonna ban.
I'm gonna ban Bruce.
I'm gonna... Oh my god, Mac.
Please don't play Storm.
Mac, I just need one more win.
I just need one more win and then I can get GM one... Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, I'm banning fucking Hawkeye.
I refuse.
I refuse to play.
I swear to god, Mac, if you...
Oh wait, okay.
Oops, I didn't realize everybody's banning Bruce Banner.
That's my bad.
My go-to has always been Hawkeye.
That's... Oh my god.
Gotta play against the Hawkeye now.
Oh my god.
And I can get GM back and then I can go back to my regular scheduled stream.
Please, Mac.
Please.
Oh my god.
Why is he on...
Yes.
Please, Mac.
Is this you telling...
Mac.
I swear to god.
Oh my god.
A desperate cry to nobody.
Who was it?
Oh.
Holacrosis.
I swear to god, your curse has made him fucking play Storm.
If I lose, it's gonna be a one week ban.
It's not even gonna be one day.
Fucking wrong.
You made him play Storm.
One of the worst characters.
And...
And Luna ban.
I swear to fucking god.
Oh my god.
And they have a fucking...
What killed me?
Oh.
Oh my god.
I don't even know what killed me.
I don't...
Oh my god.
I don't have snaps.
He's so low.
Oh my god.
Please.
I will fucking... Oh.
I'm gonna fucking slap you until you die!
Goodbye.
I'll leave.
I hate you!
Did we get it?
Oh my god.
We fucking got it.
Thank fucking god.
Oh my god.
We fucking got it.
I just gotta do the long walk.
I just gotta do the long fucking walk.
Oh my god.
There were so many bubbles.
Alright.
I don't play Adam, but he's meta, so I have to play Adam.
He's actually really good for this map though.
Like...
I prefer Adam over...
Oh my god.
This fucking...
Oh.
Mine.
Alright.
Oh.
Nice.
That's cool.
Alright, let's go.
Born again.
Let's fucking do this again.
Come on, everybody.
Come on.
Oh.
Nope, but he is born again.
Oh, I put it too late.
Alright.
That's cool.
Oh!
That's cool!
What happened to my born again?!
What is... Oh.
We're just that far?
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it didn't register.
I thought it did.
Oh my god.
Okay.
This is not great.
This is not looking so good, guys.
They have triple support.
Mantis is banned, guys.
I can't.
That's why I'm literally playing Adam.
Mantis is literally banned.
I would not be playing Adam if...
Oh my god.
Nice.
We did it, everybody.
Alright, this is fine.
Oh my god.
Dr. Strange.
Dr. Strange!
Please!
Dr. Strange.
Dr. Dr. Strange.
I swear.
The fucking god!
Oh my god, I'm just hoping this does something.
Please, stop standing into the mines.
Please, I beg of you.
Oh my god, I hope he's doing stuff over there.
I hope he's alright.
I hope he's...
Let's go!
He's over there.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Doctor Strange, Doctor Strange.
Oh, Doctor Strange.
Doctor Strange, Doctor Strange, Doctor Strange.
Oh my god.
Everything is okay.
Everything will be okay.
Why do people not die when I want them to die?
It's actually... Please wait for like one second and then I'll give you heals.
Oh my god.
God damn it.
I just need you guys.
Alright, there you go.
Doctor Strange, Doctor Strange.
Oh, Doctor Strange.
Doctor Strange, Doctor Strange, let's go.
I'm sorry, I'm brain rotted right now.
It's been really rough.
Oh my god.
Oh, goodbye.
You're so fun.
Oh my god.
We live here.
I told them.
No, no, I did not mean a cocoon!
I got him though.
Okay, that works.
That's fine.
I didn't mean a cocoon, but it works though.
Get that vehicle moving again!
That's fucking me.
I'm never going that way again.
Oh my god.
Alright.
It's fine.
Dude, I don't have enough heals.
God damn it.
Alright.
It's fine.
Look at Punisher.
There we go.
Everything is fine.
Okay, I can't.
Alright, that's fine.
That's absolutely fine.
I dove!
There is a Punisher wreck.
Okay, I'm fucking, it's time.
I have to go Jeff to get back.
I have to beat Jeff to get to my teammates in time.
Oh my god, I have to get there so I can swim.
Oh my god, what the fuck!
Fucking oh shit!
Guys, guys, no!
I got killed.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
A curse is real.
A curse is actually real.
Oh my god.
I don't know what to do.
What play?
I don't know if Adam is the play.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I'll do Loki.
Maybe Loki is it.
I feel like I was doing alright on Loki and Adam.
But like, we'll try Loki.
Adam and Loki.
Alright, if Loki doesn't work, I'll swap to Adam.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
They banned.
They banned so many characters.
See guys, it's technically God of War.
I'm on Loki.
It's technically God of War.
I'm on Loki, guys.
Where the fuck is our tank?
Okay, I was gonna say.
Where's our tank?
How do I- How am I gonna heal you?
How am I- How am I gonna heal you?
Alright.
Let's see.
There's a guy right here.
Oh, he's like whipping my guy.
He's like just whipping him.
Alright, guys.
I need you- Alright.
This is- This is not look- Kurosis, this is your fault.
This is actually- Kurosis, this is your-
Kurosis, I need you to know.
We could've had it all.
We could've had- Remember, if we don't get God of War- Now- Remember why.
Remember why.
No, I didn't leave.
It's okay, it's just me.
It's just me.
Is he- Oh my god, it fucked up my fucking clone!
God fucking- Guys, I- Mac,
I - I swear to god.
I'm fucking- I'm fucking running.
I'm gonna fucking run.
I'm gonna fucking- I'm fucking running.
I'm fucking- Oh my god.
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
I- I don't think- Oh my god, why do we have a widow?
Why the fuck do we have a widow?
I don't play DPS!
I don't- What the fuck?
Go.
You triple- Sup.
It's meta.
Oh my god, he's actually one.
What are you- Why is he like- I don't do it.
I don't do it!
I don't do DPS!
Just go triple support!
Oh.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, go triple sup- support.
Oh my god.
I don't understand.
Why didn't you go triple support earlier?
Why- Why didn't you go triple-
Really?
That's all that we needed.
Please kill the clone.
Don't make me be the only one.
Guys, not only did Mac-
This - This double curse you guys did for me.
Not only did like- Did like- I have triple- I have triple support players.
But it made Mac play Storm.
Which by the way, he has never played Storm before.
This is the second thing.
I'm sorry.
Remember what you've all done.
Hmm.
Okay.
Alright.
I have to do this.
Just in case.
Oh my god.
Second chance is over.
Okay, this is where I die.
This is actually where I die.
We have no second chance.
Who the fuck got swapped?
Oh my god.
Alright.
Not ideal.
Alright, we're banning Mac.
I'm gonna fucking ban- I- Oh my god.
What?
Where was that?
It showed up last minute.
She actually threw that the moment I peeked the door.
That's actually crazy.
Mac.
Oh my god.
Alright, one week ban.
One week ban.
I'm fucking ready.
I'm fucking ready for my one week ban.
Oh yeah.
Alright, I'm fucking trying to- I'm trying to kill- Please, he's so low.
No.
No, no, no, no, no.
I fucking got- Oh, thank god.
No,
you fucking go, Jeff.
Oh my god, he was actually so low though.
Oh my god.
Oh, bad guy.
Good luck.
Oh, good luck to me too.
Good luck to me.
Good luck.
No!
I'm cocooning, I'm cocooning.
I couldn't- I couldn't die!
Alright, goodbye.
One week ban.
One- You said you would come!
What happened?!
You stopped and turned the face around!
No, you didn't!
Ben!
We had nothing!
That curse, I should- Oh my god.
Alright.
Alright, who else cursed?
I'm fucking hitting all of you.
You guys tripled it.
Alright.
Tequila burrito, one week ban.
El Mexican, one week ban.
So you guys gotta ban them later.
Exactly one week.
One week ban!
This could've been over!
Mack!
Please!
I need a stream cut or more!
My dragoons are crying!
Mack, please.
Okay, okay.
If we win the next two games, I will get the hundred.
Get me out of here.
So you better get me out of here.
Get out of here.
Okay, alright.
You don't understand.
You don't understand, guys.
I felt like I was being fucking held hostage.
I feel like I'm being fucking held hostage right now.
I swear, if he was not on Storm, and he was on literally all the characters, like Starlord or anything, it would've been okay.
I'm holding you guys hostage because my duo is holding me hostage right now.
Literally, all I needed was...
Starlord last game.
This is the second time I've ever seen Mack on Storm.
And Storm is considered the lowest tier pick for Marvel Rivals.
I don't see Storm players.
The only people who are fucking crazy enough to play Storm are people who are fucking Storm 1 tricks.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
I'm okay.
Everything will be fine.
Three supports is okay, too.
Oh my god.
Okay, focus, Jokey.
It's time to focus.
It's time to fucking focus right here.
Thank god I can aim.
Isaiah is like, I'm not shooting anything.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh, you're gonna be fine.
You're gonna be so healthy.
Oh my god, what the fuck was he trying to do?
Is he dead yet?
Oh, there he is.
Alright.
Everything is fine.
Everything is okay.
Alright, that's fine.
I don't think we should have...
Guys, why did we all just stood there and let this happen?
Why did we all...
I'm fine with stalling a little longer.
Oh my god, we just stood there.
Just got fucking, like, eaten up in that hallway.
Alright, this is fine.
Your Curse of Ra actually fucking built, like, stacked upon each other.
Because I have three support players on my team.
I, like, I...
I'm gonna go crazy.
I'm gonna...
Alright.
I'm gonna fucking...
Woah.
Okay.
Wait, do we have...
Nope.
I was gonna say, do we have...
We don't have Mantis ulti, die first.
Why?
Wait, why?
Oh my god.
Why?
Okay, oh wait, that's...
Oh my god.
Why?
We're trickling down.
Alright.
Okay.
You're fine.
We're so fine.
We're so fucking fine.
Okay, he missed.
Yeah, we're so healthy.
He actually missed.
There we go.
Please, she's actually one.
Please, like...
Please, guys.
I will sit here.
There we go.
I'm sitting here in case I have to rez.
I'm sitting here.
Guys, I don't...
I don't know about sitting there.
Guys, I...
First time it didn't work.
I don't know what is gonna be different this time around.
What's gonna be different this time?
I don't understand.
Wait.
Killed one, killed one.
Whoa.
There we go.
Wait, are they walking apart?
Solo, solo, guys.
Solo, there's one.
Please.
I'm ulting that one, though.
Throw one, throw one, throw one.
We're so low.
Look at the rune, look at the rune.
Don't swing, don't swing.
Okay, like, I don't know what you want me to do.
Okay, I feel like I need...
This is a rez situation.
This is definitely a rez situation.
This is a rez situation right there.
This is...
Get on, get on, get on, get on.
Get on.
Oh my god.
Oh, that's huge, that's huge.
That's huge.
That's so huge.
I did that.
Oh my god, I fucking did that.
I did it.
I rest my team.
I fucking rest my team.
I can't believe...
I still can't believe...
Mac went storm.
His comp stopped working.
And then we had three supports last game.
You actually stacked up all the fucking curses possible in that one fucking game.
That's actually...
This is why all three of you, all three of you deserve that one fucking weak ban.
Okay.
Don't worry, I'll come.
Suddenly fucking game doesn't allow them to come.
Alright.
Here we go.
It's fine.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I believe in us.
We're a fucking team.
I believe.
Oh my god, he's okay.
Oh my god, he's so okay.
He's so healthy.
Okay.
Oh my god, I was not okay.
I'm gonna un-cocoon.
We had no support ults for this.
Alright.
It's fine.
Yes, don't worry.
Don't worry.
We just need...
Holy...
I'm snapping, I'm snapping my hands.
Alright.
I'm dead, but that's okay.
You...
Okay.
Nevermind.
You might have needed me, but that's okay.
I don't think they live.
No, they definitely do not live.
No, they definitely are dead dead.
I might be dead dead too.
I'll cocoon.
Please don't look at me.
Please.
No, Mantis.
Why did you cocoon, Mantis?
Get over here, Mantis.
Oh my god, you won your 1v1.
That's my support.
Trio.
Okay, Mantis.
Our tank is over here.
Our tank.
Oh, we're fine.
You're fine.
You're so fine.
That's fine.
As long as we're all okay, right?
Right?
Are we all okay?
Oh, we are not okay.
Nevermind.
I thought...
I didn't realize she was still gonna run at us.
I...
I really...
Oh, but we opened the portal.
We won't have...
Oh, no.
No, strange.
We shouldn't open the portal.
Okay.
The portal might be...
Yeah, I was gonna say.
This is definitely a bad idea.
I was gonna say.
The portal is not it.
The portal is definitely not it.
Alright, who cursed me again?
Guys, who were the new cursers that cursed this game?
Who was it?
Give me the names.
I hope my mods are writing down who cursed this one.
Alright, the more curses you put, the longer the ban is gonna get.
I need...
I need you guys to know that.
So, like, whoever cursed this game, one month.
No, two weeks.
Whoever...
Whoever cursed this, two weeks.
Two...
I need you guys to learn.
I need you guys to learn not to curse me no more.
Oh, you guys...
You guys wonder why it's two weeks?
Cause some of you didn't learn from the first two bans.
This is my naughty list.
Someone...
Someone didn't learn about after the first two bans.
Yeah, you're here yet again.
You guys gotta know.
We should be, like, okay, right?
We technically should be okay.
Alright.
Jesus Christ.
We gotta avoid some...
We gotta avoid some people here.
Like, I can't...
I can't fucking...
Oh my god.
How...
How many...
What is going on?
How...
I can't see anything!
Oh my god.
Huge whale.
See you in two weeks!
You guys better have learned your lesson.
Just remember...
Guys, where did everybody go?
Where...
Where did everybody go?
Where did...
Where did everybody...
Okay, we're...
Okay, that's where everybody went.
I was gonna say, where did everyone go?
Oh my god, he's, like, actual low.
Oh my god.
Come on!
Guys, I don't think we're winning this one.
I...
I don't think we're...
Guys...
I've actually...
I think I've actually lost hope.
I...
I think...
I think it's over.
Oh my god.
It's just you and I.
I'm avoiding one of the supports.
I...
I keep wearing one game off.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
That was three games off.
Who was it?
Alright.
Write the name for the one...
For the two week ban.
The...
The second game...
This next game.
If you curse me and I lose this game...
That's a three week ban.
That's a fucking three week ban.
You have to learn.
You guys have to learn.
I literally needed one game.
I just needed one game.
And then you stacked all the bans together.
You actually stacked it all together.
Oh my god.
Please.
I need counter curse.
I need like...
Counter curses to the Curse of Ra, chat.
I need...
Guys, please.
We need a counter.
We need a counter all the curses.
If you counter the Curse of Ra...
I will...
I will acknowledge you.
I will put your name...
On the...
Ending screen.
Oh, we got CrashBad.
He plays Tank but he always...
Why?
Who was it?
Who the fuck?
Who did this?
Alright, write the names down.
This is the three week.
Do you want to take the gamble?
I need the Hawkeye.
I need the fucking counter curses.
I hope my mods are writing their names down.
Do like a 20%.
Holy shit.
Oh.
I'm gonna fucking go crazy.
I'm gonna go crazy for this game.
You curse me on this game?
Three weeks.
I'm going up every week.
I'm going every game.
I'm going up a week.
I can't.
You might as well just make a new account at this point.
If you want to talk in my chat again.
You might as well just make a new account.
Or you'll never be able to interact here.
You'll never be able to interact in this chat at this point.
I thought so too.
Alright.
Doki's chat becomes unreadable.
Do you just want to teleport top or do you just want to walk down mid?
Alright.
Here we go.
I'm gonna teleport here.
Alright.
Let's go.
There's a Luna set up top.
Let's fucking go.
What the fuck?
It like glitched out for me.
That was so weird.
Oh, they have a magic?
Oh!
Oh my god!
My god!
There's so much damage.
Magic dead.
Yeah, but five of us are dead.
Oh my god.
Yeah, the magic's dead.
Yeah.
I wish we had like, you know, an equal amount of trade there too.
Oh!
Oh my god.
I have no shield.
No shield.
Jesus Christ.
Why don't you guys walk in?
I'm walking.
I don't do that.
I'm gonna try to kill that guy.
I'm frozen.
Oh my god!
I'm fighting.
Bro, I'm fucking...
I'm frozen too!
Our fucking naughty list.
I will recruit a third person if it means I have to get out of here.
Please.
It will take up god of war time.
Guys, the more you curse me...
The less god of war you get.
I'll give you...
Alright, I was planning on doing a four hour god of war stream.
I just need you guys to know that.
The more you stall this...
It will take up a god of war time slot.
That's right.
There's more...
Are you serious?
Are you...
Oh my god.
We're so fucking dead in here.
We're so...
Chris, I died.
Why did you...
Why did you put it there?
What do you mean you're lagging?
Why did all the curses build up to you?
I have a teleport in nine if you want to try that again.
No, I do not want to try that again.
We can get our Adam and poke it out.
Our Bucky.
Alright.
Oh my god, thank you for the counter curse.
Thank you.
Thank you for the counter curse.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for counter cursing this fucking hellhole that I'm trapped in.
This purgatory that I'm trapped in.
I really appreciate it.
Oh my god.
I got judge, jury, executioner.
Four games.
We're at four games now, chat.
We're at...
I can force touch point.
You have to.
There's magic behind all of us.
Sorry Adam.
I'm gonna lose it.
That one game was the game.
That was actually the game.
Oh my god.
Who was the one that cursed me on that one game?
Change it to one month.
All the people.
That one game.
That's gotta be the hard.
Change it to one month.
That's not one week anymore.
It's one month.
What?
That one game.
That one game where I was one game away back to GM one.
They gotta learn.
That was Lord Kuro's.
Now it's one month.
How is he innocent?
He knew exactly what he was doing.
And he still did it.
Two hours later.
Change it to a year.
He is not innocent.
You are not protecting a criminal.
You are not protecting a fucking criminal in my chat.
I didn't lie.
I was gonna fucking play God of War right after.
But somebody.
Not even somebody.
A couple of you guys were like.
Would it be funny if she plays a little longer?
Let me fucking give her as much bad luck as possible.
Okay.
I don't know what you want but.
Yep.
Sure.
I don't feel like I'm winning.
I don't.
Not gonna lie.
Oh my God.
We're alive.
For like one more round.
Oh my God.
I can't believe we're alive for one more fight.
I can't believe it guys.
I can't believe we're alive for one more round.
Oh the fuck?
Oh.
Yeah.
My God.
I'm fucking scroll wheeling it so fucking hard right now.
Alright we're fucking dead.
We're so dead.
Goodbye everybody.
We've got a war going on.
We've got a war.
I can't believe this is a God.
No guys.
I swear to God.
We just need Counter Curse.
Exactly!
Dude you know what?
Everyone that cataclyses, you're maude for the- for like, you're maude for the day.
All the cataclyses, I'm giving you maude for the day.
Ain't no way.
That's right.
Don't- dude, I'm just kidding.
Despy's gone mad.
That's right.
Congratulations!
You get to start a chat war.
That's actually right.
I'm gonna start the biggest fucking war in my chat.
But don't keep being cursed.
All right, this game?
Four weeks.
Four weeks, this game.
All right, June, congratulations.
You're maude for the day.
I hate Hello, but I hate Spider-Man at the same time.
Congratulations!
Maude for the day.
All right, Sandor Maude, there you go.
All right, there you go.
Congratulations, maude for the- no, no, maude for the stream.
No, I shouldn't do maude for the day.
That's actually pretty fucked up.
Maude for the rest of the stream, and then we unmaude you right after the stream.
Maude for the rest of the stream.
I have fucking lost it.
I- I've absolutely lost it.
I need- I need to get out of here.
I need to get to GM1.
I- I like get lazy.
What?
All right, you get to be maude for the rest of the stream.
I'll rip- don't worry, I'll remove it right after.
Oh shit, wait, you're right.
Wait, no, they can't.
They don't have the power to unban, only I do.
Only I have the power to unban.
A discord admin reneged me from Marvel Rivals to conquer it, so I'll ramp up the curse and extend the ban.
A blessing.
All right, maude for the rest of the stream.
Congratulations, maude for the rest of the stream.
Four weeks and a month is the same.
All right, here we go.
If I- if you unban, okay, also the maude's who are like maude for the rest of the day.
Maude's for the rest of the day.
Uh, for the rest of the stream, I will- if you unban any of the people I just banned, I will fuck- your- your maude's getting removed.
You're- you can't- your maude's getting removed and then you're getting banned.
That's right, you think I won't do it?
I'm fucking crazy.
I'm playing this game since two in the morning.
Or three in the morning.
I just- I fucking- I'm- I'm hyped up on gamer subs right now.
And we have three tanks.
This is going great.
I'm fucking- that's right.
That's right, I'm fucking- it's over.
That's when you know.
That's when you know, like, I'm not joking around.
I'm not fucking around.
I'm- I'm- I'll do anything.
That's when you know.
Oh, where did he go?
Wait, where did he go?
Wait, I have to solo heal us.
Wait, I have to solo heal.
Wait, the Punisher still died.
Wait, the Punisher died!
No,
wait, no, I will remember to unwind.
I'll remember.
I don't think we should go three tanks, guys.
I don't think so.
Guys, I actually wanted to play God of War, but like, you don't understand.
I need to get back my GM1.
You don't understand.
Okay, I got focus up, actually.
I actually need to focus up because we have three fucking tanks.
Like, how do I heal this?
How do I heal three?
Why do we have three tanks?
It's clearly not working.
Oh my god.
Why is Mek on record?
Oh, he hid there.
Okay, okay, I need to actually focus up now.
Oh my god, this is actually a game I have to fucking pay attention to because I have to keep three tanks alive.
Which is not great.
Oh my god.
I don't think this is the right idea, guys.
Oh my god, just shoot everything.
Just, please.
I can't even see anything.
I can't see anything.
There we go, you should be dead.
All right, all right.
I don't think I can tell anyone what just happened that fight.
Three minutes.
Three minutes left.
Psy top here, she just dashed off.
We have like four, three tank things.
All right.
Oh.
Okay, focus up, Psy.
You're so healthy.
All right.
All right, this is fun.
This is so fun.
They know what they did.
They're in jail for a reason.
You want me to free a fucking criminal?
All right.
All right, that's cool.
I need literally two.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
I just gotta be alive.
It's actually a lot harder than you think it will be.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
Not fine.
Okay, I have to save- oh my god.
I actually- I have to save Manta's ult for Psylocke.
I can't use it for anything else, which sucks.
I actually have to save it for- I feel like we need to take better account where that Iron Man is playing.
Okay, he killed one person.
Like, it's not like- Bro, bro.
Bro, I can't.
Bro, I- I- STOP!
STOP PEEKING HIM!
I literally am using every fucking leap on you.
Like- Iron Man over top of them.
I don't have enough!
Psy, name Psy, Psy.
I don't have enough heals for all of you!
There's one.
Oh my god, I didn't want to.
Watch it, watch it, watch it.
Nice.
Oh my god, please.
Very slow.
I stunned him.
Please!
I stunned her after, I stunned her.
Good sleep?
Oh yeah.
She's gonna roll.
It doesn't matter.
Can't you stab?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna stun her out of it.
Okay.
I'm gonna stun.
Oh, holy fuck.
Please!
I don't have enough heals!
Good ult.
Straight in her ass.
Please, I actually don't have enough!
Oh my god.
Please.
I'm stalling it by being on here.
No, he's one!
He's one!
Fuck.
I was yelling at my chat.
Why do we have three?
He's dead.
I messed out on this comp.
My chat cursed the game that would have got me a G1 and won.
And fucking killed your BC.
BC.
Alp is a pro player.
Let him DPS.
They are crying!
I'm banning you from my chat.
Oh my god.
I don't even know what his YouTube channel is.
I was like, we need another DPS player.
And then like literally...
Literally our other DPS player is forced on support.
It was actually so cursed.
It was actually so fucking cursed.
I got some money.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Okay.
That's cool.
That's so cool.
Like...
I...
They wouldn't even...
They wouldn't even let Mag DPS up there.
Oh my...
I think we need like more heals.
Like...
Maybe like a slow instead of the warlock.
They banned Luna.
Luna's banned.
Oh my god.
Like...
I think our whole team banned Luna.
I just go over here.
I'll just be over here guys.
We're avoiding people.
I can't.
I'm avoiding...
Now we have too many tanks.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh!
Servers at 224 ping!
I...
Alright.
I can't keep track of it.
I need my mods to keep track of the naughty list.
I...
I actually...
I... Where am I?
I'm... I need...
I need the mods to keep track of the naughty list now.
I...
I need them to keep track.
Cause like I can't see shit.
Oh!
Now it stopped lagging!
That's cool.
It literally stopped lagging.
Hahaha.
We Q dodge everything.
He's outside of the fucking map?!
He's outside...
I... What?!
That's right.
It's the bad list.
It's the fucking bad list.
I'm gonna kill this Iron Man.
Oh!
Fucking run you little whore.
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna report this guy.
I'm gonna report him.
I'm gonna fucking report him.
I hope he knows I'm gonna report him.
I hope he fucking knows.
He needs to know.
I'm gonna report him.
I think Groot walled me into the fucking...
Symbio did push me in the wall.
I'm in.
Oh my god.
It's five teams.
Holy fuck.
No, Mac.
We could have won.
If you were on anyone.
But Storm.
It would have been so free.
You could...
You could have killed...
You
can't say that when you avoid Storm players.
He fucking avoids Storm players.
He fucking says that.
No, no.
I avoid Squirrel players.
I remember in that one game you cried because we had a Storm one trick.
But we still won because we
Oh my god.
I'm like two losses.
I am two losses away.
What?
Oh my god.
I am two losses away.
I am...
Alright.
I might have to...
God, I might need reinforcements if I can't...
I'm tempted to ask an Eternity player and be like, do you wanna play?
Oh wait.
I don't know anymore.
I don't think this Eternity player...
Oh my god.
I don't want to make him lose.
Nevermind.
He's not having a good day too, guys.
He's not.
He's not having a good day as well.
He's not having a good day as well, guys.
So I might not be a great time for him as well.
I might not be as...
Nah, Surefour doesn't want to duo.
He wants to solo.
He's been on a solo grind.
I think it's like he wants to solo for the Eternity and stuff.
Guys, I...
This is not...
No, Jirard, my dragons have cursed all my...
Streaming my arrivals was a mistake.
I should've just delayed the stream until I got it.
I should've...
I should've just delayed the stream until I fucking got it.
Streaming my arrivals was a mistake.
I shouldn't have streamed my arrival.
I sincerely apologize for my dumbass and big penance.
Are you the Penny?!
That reminded me.
I forgot to report.
Thank you.
Thank you for the awkward superchat.
Was that you?!
What's it about?
Oh my god.
Self reported.
Dude, too late.
I'm holding God of War hostage.
That's fucking right.
That's...
I will fucking hold God of War hostage until I get this over with.
Until...
It's too... How long have I been playing?
I've been playing for an hour and a ha...
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
He is a pro player in Apex.
He is a pro player.
Oh my god, who said that?
Oh my god, you said that.
Oh my god.
Thanks, man.
I'm on a lost streak, though.
I shouldn't say that.
He's like, oh my god, Dirk is the best support player in Oregon.
I was like, oh, that's sweet.
That's so sweet of him.
I'm on a lost streak, though.
I'm on a...
I didn't say it!
I didn't say it.
Please,
please play.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, should have fucking lost me that game.
Now we're fucking here until we get it back.
Should have fucking lost that game.
This is punishment.
Alright, focus up.
Okay.
There we go.
He dead.
He fucking dead.
I'm fucking getting closer.
I'm fucking getting in on the sauce.
I'm getting in on the sauce.
That's fucking right.
I'm fucking getting in.
I'm getting fucking in.
I'm fucking I'm fucking... Oh, shit!
I'm not getting in anymore!
Oh my god.
I'm not getting back in anymore.
That shit was scary, not gonna lie.
Wait, did I just saw something to my right?
No.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Oh,
we gotta get on point, guys.
No, we're not cooked!
We're not cooked!
Oh, nevermind.
We're cooked.
We're a little cooked.
Guys, do you think money is gonna stop me from playing Marvel Rivals?
You guys have to learn that no amount of money will save you from this fucking hostage situation.
All I care about are rank points.
You think money is gonna fix it?
Hahaha.
It's all about the rank points.
Okay, guys, guys.
Oh, they blocked it, I see.
Okay, yeah, I'm backing up.
Oh, shit!
He's so dead.
There's no way.
I'm so dead, too.
I'm not!
Giga, thank you for the akka-akka-supa.
Thank you.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Don't worry, we will we will get it.
Guys, I swear.
My god.
Okay.
I literally, oh my god.
Wait, it's still possible.
We can contest this.
We can get here.
Okay, nope.
We gotta go this way.
This is how Limbo's gonna look like.
Streaming this was a mistake.
But it's too late.
I'm committed now.
How long will this stream be?
Let's find out.
I'm fully committed now.
We'll see how long this stream is gonna be, guys.
We're gonna see.
How long will this stream be?
Woah.
Oh,
guys.
I think I think he's dead.
Yeah, I fucking put all my heals on it.
Yeah.
He's gonna be playing Limbo.
Oh,
shit.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Oh, shit.
I should heal.
No, does he not know I'm right here?
Cause I was too busy DPSing and missing my shots.
Alright.
I have no idea where I'm shooting at right now.
I can't see shit.
Legitimately, I can't see anything.
Alright, here we go.
I'm not gonna have a chat anymore with all these bans.
I'm not gonna have a chat no more.
We are invincible!
They have eyes looking for it.
He's 100% looking for it.
Where am I?
He taxied me to the other side!
That was so close.
Alright.
Here we go.
I can!
Let's go!
I touched.
I
could!
I saw it!
I stayed on it!
Alright.
Six games.
You know what?
Drop the fucking Trinity player in here and be like, hey, you wanna join in?
Are you fucking dumb, bro?
Did you even just hear what I said?
If I hit a three man whale and I can kill three of them why is my group putting walls in front of me
You're right.
He's supposed to read your mind on when you're gonna ult.
Oh my god.
It's not looking so great.
Guys.
I'm gonna drag the one above all one above all into this shit show.
I'm gonna make him lose g. I'm gonna make him lose one above all.
I'm gonna lose it all.
I'm gonna make sure people lose it all with me.
Oh my god.
No, I didn't turn it off.
I wanna make sure it was so loud.
I wanna make sure everybody could hear what they're saying.
If you fall that's so messed up.
Alright.
I got this.
He is rude.
He is.
He's still rude.
He is rude.
He's rude.
I'm shaping my little hidey hole.
Wow.
Look at my little hidey hole that I have.
Right here.
Yeah.
I am rude.
Look at that.
Look at that little hidey hole that I have.
Oh, what's the current win-loss ratio?
I was winning so much before the stream started.
Isn't that fucking crazy?
And then...
Some fucking curse hit me.
And I was like...
That was the worst that could happen.
Um...
A lot, apparently.
A lot could happen.
Isn't that crazy?
A lot happened.
A lot.
Oh my god, Grutab.
Grutab.
This was a lot of ults, but that's okay.
Like...
Fuck all of these guys, I guess.
Oh my god!
Let's just use everything, guys!
Let's go!
Alright.
This is fine.
I'm so focused.
Alright.
I'm...
I'm focused.
I don't know about others.
But I'm so focused.
Oh my god.
I'm so focused.
Okay.
Alright, let's go.
Let's fucking go!
Just fucking...
There we go.
Damn.
Alright, nice.
Let's go.
There we go.
And then I'll give you my little damage boost while I stand here.
And then...
And then I'll give you more damage boost.
And then I'll give you the little heal while we stand here.
And then...
I'll give you more, and then I'll give you this.
And then I'll give you this.
And then we go in.
We fucking go the fuck in.
We go in.
And then we go back.
And then we back out.
Okay, alright.
That's fine.
They popped three ults for one of my...
Guys, they literally popped three ults for one of mine.
So like...
That's fine.
I think that's like the best trade I could get.
Not gonna lie.
That's such a good trade.
C'mon.
Alright, there you go.
C'mon, shoot him.
Um...
What?
It was... Oh!
This is where I die.
Why couldn't Mindstrange do that?
What?
Why couldn't Mindstrange do something as cool as that?
That's crazy.
That was so cool.
It would be so cool if it happens to like our team.
Am I getting shot by something?
Okay.
That's fucking right, bitch.
Get out.
That's fucking right.
I'm also trying to farm my ult too.
Alright, you guys...
Alright.
Alright, I...
I leave here.
Everything is fine.
That's right, Groot!
C'mon.
That's right!
Alright, I guess I'll push the cart myself.
Right, guys?
Right?
Alright, let's go!
He has eyes!
Is he... Is he...
Oh, he is not.
Okay.
I'm a little worried now.
I'm... I'm a little worried here.
I don't think...
Guys, I don't think we're gonna live.
I don't...
I don't think... Oh wait, I live.
Let's go.
Oh, I don't think they're gonna live though.
Yeah, they're definitely not gonna live.
Oh my god, what's slowing me down?
Okay, but they won't know I'm right here.
I have to go back downstairs.
That's fine.
Okay, that's not fine.
That's not fine.
Oh my god!
What?
Why?
Holy shit!
They just ran into that turret just like that!
Here we go.
Goodbye, rocket.
I hope you live.
Alright, here we go.
You go do your damage.
Me too.
Oh, they have Moon Knight.
I can see it.
I see it.
They have Moon Knight.
Alright.
It's fine.
It's not fine, guys.
I think we all realize how not fine this is right now.
Like...
I think...
I think we all realize...
Oh my god!
I'm just trying to make sure...
Oh!
I'm trying to make sure you're all...
I can't!
I ran out of lead!
I ran out of fucking lead!
Guys, no.
Reyna will be fine.
I don't think we can get a portal in time.
There's no way.
But I'll touch it here.
What the fuck?
Wait.
Wait, what?
Wait a minute, what?
Ouch!
Guys, we still have to defend.
We still have to defend!
What?
That worked?
That actually worked?
Oh my god!
I don't know if we can defend it, but like...
I don't know if we can defend it, but wow!
Alright.
Here we go.
This is fine.
We're gonna see Ragnarok.
We're gonna see dad back, guys.
We're gonna see dad, guys.
Oh, thank you, Leon, for extending your luck to me.
Thank you, Leon.
It's been two hours.
I've been playing Marble Rivals for two hours now.
It doesn't even feel like two hours.
I feel like I didn't even realize it's two hours past.
It feels like one hour of Marble Rivals.
Marble Rivals.
Let's just stand here in the center.
Let's just stand here.
What the...
Where am I?
Oh, guys!
That ain't it!
No!
I almost got it!
Guys, that was definitely not it.
That was not it.
What was that TP?
What the fuck?
Can we touch it?
No!
Oh my god!
What happened?
What's going on?
Oh no, they're gonna push up after that.
They're gonna push up here.
I don't know what the fuck happened though.
Legitimately, I don't know what happened.
I don't know what happened here.
Oh my god.
What's going on?
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
What's going on?
No escape.
No survivors.
Oh my god.
What the fuck was going on?
Can't be that close.
It's okay.
Things will be okay, guys.
I'm 35.
Oh my god.
He has 56.
How does he have 56?
I can't wait to drag... I hope that other guy, that's one above all.
I can't wait to drag him down with me.
I'm gonna... I can't wait.
I did it.
We're gonna go to God of War.
The moment we get back GM... Guys, I swear.
Guys, I swear to god.
The moment we get back GM 1, we'll be back to God of War, guys.
I swear.
Please believe in me.
Also, I need to...
I swear.
I swear, everybody.
We will play God of War today.
It will happen.
No.
No, we don't need to change the stream title, guys.
We don't.
It'll be fine.
I'm playing the game of my fucking life right now.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
This is fine.
Going down main, okay.
That's smart, though.
Honestly, that's really smart of them.
I would.
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Trying to farm leaves right now.
No.
Inspire.
Bitch!
Get over here.
I'm a little scared.
I don't have cover anymore.
Okay, team, it's alright.
Where's the portal?
Where's the...
I don't see it.
I'm just herding it.
Wait, that's huge!
That's huge!
That's my keyring!
That's really...
That's where I fucking run.
Fucking run.
Three, two, one.
Yes!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Yes!
I have hope!
From that one game, I received hope!
Oh my god!
Whoever tried to curse this, you're okay, my dude.
You don't get to be...
You don't have to be banned now.
Oh my god!
No, you don't have to...
You don't get banned!
Congratulations!
Simpleminded, thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
No, I swear to god, I will play.
I will play.
What?
Excuse me.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, here we go.
This is fun.
Guys, I feel hope now.
I have a hope.
No, that's a good curse.
Okay,
here we go.
Wait, not Hawkeye?
What if they don't ban Hawkeye?
Oh, thank god.
Thank fucking god, I was gonna...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, this is fun.
There's no good times up here.
Does he know he's open?
Does he know?
Oh, that's a good combo.
Oh, you should be a voice actor.
No.
Who is he talking to?
Why don't you become a voice actor?
Do you know what a voice actor is?
What the fuck?
Do you think a voice actor of um...
be a good character?
Wait, hold on.
You know what?
I don't know anybody.
No, I would never lie.
Simple-minded.
I would never lie.
Don't worry, we're gonna have God of War.
Dad's coming back.
He just needs to play a couple more Marvel Rival games.
It's like a gambling addiction, but much, much worse.
Cause I don't win any money.
But I lose a lot.
It is possibly much worse than gambling.
I wish I have a gambling addiction.
Okay.
Rude, what the fuck was Groot doing here?
Alright, focus up.
Focus up, Doki.
You got this.
Just do what you gotta do.
Okay.
No, no.
Dad's coming back.
Dude, I can't even give him the bubble.
Yo, kill Star-Lord.
No, kill him.
He's one HP.
Everybody, one Venom.
Alright, nice.
Run away.
I haven't seen a good Venom.
It's like they just feed, dude.
It's like they can't even play characters like that.
I couldn't.
Alright.
That was a sick freeze.
But to be fair, his hitbox was fucking giant as fuck.
I'm gonna give it to Mac, actually.
Oh, he's so low.
Oh, two support ults.
Let's go.
That's what I like to see.
There we go.
Oh my god, that's what I like to see.
Okay.
Is everybody okay?
Are you guys okay?
The other two are not.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, we're fine.
We're all so Gucci.
That's fine.
No, I'm not pocketing you, Black Panther.
I have a duo.
There we go.
See, look at that.
I'm so locked in.
What's he gonna do?
The one thing I really did not want him to do.
He didn't.
I was like, he's gonna fucking ult.
There's no way.
There's no way he's gonna ult, guys.
There it is.
Alright, goodbye, everybody.
Like, I don't have anything for that.
Alright, here we go.
What's he gonna do?
I didn't even get to finish my sentence and he still did it.
I didn't even get a chance to finish my sentence.
Oh my god, she's one!
She's actually one.
Oh, I missed it.
Oh, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Alright.
You're fine.
You're so fine.
That's fine, just silence.
That's so good for us!
That's so good for us, actually.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Get over here, get over here.
Dance in my fucking ult.
Dance!
Dance in it!
And then I leave!
Oh my god!
It doesn't matter.
I still got fucked up.
It's fine.
Like, we're up?
I can't tell.
Oh, we're definitely up.
Hello, I'm up here.
Oh, we're definitely- Where am I?
Where am I?
In this fucking room.
Please, just focus on Venom.
Oh, no.
Please.
He's literally one.
Alright, we're fine.
We're still healthy.
Oh my god.
Oh, fuck!
Nice.
We're okay, too.
This is fine, too.
Oh, okay.
Here we go.
I'm so- I have one death.
That means I'm playing my fucking heart out right now.
I'm playing my goddamn heart out now, guys.
That one win we got, I feel so fucking inspired.
Like, I'm so inspired now.
I hit the fucking wall.
Okay.
Now I feel inspired.
Okay, I feel inspired now.
Please get over here.
You're so alive.
You're so healthy.
I told you guys, I feel so inspired.
You're so alive.
Okay.
Okay, um, kill Venom.
Please.
He's so low.
Nice.
I will- We're pushing.
We're pushing.
Go get your ult charged.
Guys, guys, get in here.
Get in here.
Alright, let's dance and point, guys.
Let's fucking dance.
Oh no.
Guys, this is not- Guys, just- How did I- Who did I kill?
Oh,
I'm here.
Back.
I'm back.
Oh, goodbye.
I'm not back.
We just didn't kill Venom.
We just- We just didn't kill Venom.
Oh, we killed Venom!
Here we go.
Oh my god.
There was just too much damage.
There was so much.
Oh, we were so close.
We could defend it, right?
Oh my god.
Okay, we can defend this.
I'm inspired.
We did so well last game.
Wait, is there a black bar?
Oh my god, is my game not aligned?
Wait, there's no way.
No, it's supposed to be a black bar.
No, okay.
Oh, thank god.
You guys, like, actually freaked me out.
There is a black bar right here.
Wait, is it?
Is it part of the game?
I can't tell.
That's part of the game, right?
Yeah, it is.
It is.
It is part of the game.
Okay, you guys, like, actually got me so paranoid.
You guys were...
No, it is.
It literally is.
I have it on my screen.
I have the black bar.
It's like I knew it.
You guys fucked with me.
No, it's still there.
I literally see it.
I see it.
It's always been there.
Guys, it's always been... Guys.
Guys, it's fine.
We can defend this.
I'm locked in.
And after this, we're gonna drag that one-above-all guy into this stack.
And then, because, like, I need everyone to suffer.
If Chad is holding me hostage, then I'm gonna go out of war hostage.
And I'm also gonna hold everybody else in my stack hostage.
This is...
Oh, you're winning?
Hehehe.
I'm gonna hold everybody.
Oh, wait.
UI is off.
Oh, wait a minute.
I fucked it up.
Oh, no.
I moved it.
And I fucked it up.
Okay, this is bad.
Now the UI is off.
Oh, my god.
Everything is wrong.
Everything is going wrong, guys.
Everything is going wrong.
Oh, my god.
Okay.
It's fine.
I'll fix it when I'm dead.
I'll fix it when I'm dead, guys.
Oh, my god.
You kidnapped him.
It's fine.
Oh, my...
How did you...
I actually don't know how you died.
That was actually...
That was a lot of damage.
That was...
That was a lot of...
That is still a lot of damage.
Oh, my god.
Okay, I have to use it.
I have to use it.
It was either that or I fucking died.
I had to.
It was...
A risk that I had to take.
It was that or I fucking died.
I didn't want to die.
I really did not want to die.
And lose a point because of it.
Alright.
We can live through this, right?
We just...
You can revive me with...
I don't know how to get him.
That's fine.
Where is the store lord?
Do it.
Adam is going to die though.
He is going to die.
No!
He is dead.
But I got him.
It's fine.
I saved your life.
You don't need to thank me.
Alright.
Nice.
God, I'm good at this game.
Why can't I climb?
I'm so good.
Oh god.
Get him.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Keep your fucking shield up.
Please.
What's going on on my screen?
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Go Wolverine!
Go!
Goodbye Wolverine.
Goodbye.
Oh!
Please!
Why did he fucking go again?
I was so happy.
I can't believe it.
Oh fuck.
Who did that?
Who fucking did that?
I froze there.
Also, I realized we could have had a Mantis this entire time.
We could have had a fucking Mantis.
Mantis was playing.
Adam was a choice.
I should have thought Mantis was fed.
Although...
I can't believe it was a fucking choice!
It's never...
It's usually never a choice.
That's why I was like why is he avoiding me?
No you're not.
Oh my god.
Oh you're so healthy.
I'm fucking insane.
Okay.
Mantis first.
Oh my god.
I almost threw that.
Yeah, we just pop in.
That was like Mantis first.
Please ult!
Oh my god.
Oh dickhead.
Okay.
I was gonna be very scared.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh fuck you.
That's so many ults!
Chill!
Oh my god!
That was everything!
Oh my god, okay.
Alright.
Fuck you too.
Oh my god, Wolverine.
You're fucking crazy.
Alright.
Alright, fucking nothing.
Don't you love it when the ult gets absolutely nothing?
Oh!
Oh my god.
I have no heals.
Oh my god!
I fucking gave it!
I'm alive!
Oh my god!
We did it!
Fucking nice!
Holy shit!
We actually lived!
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
We actually fucking lived through all that hell hole that we were in.
Alright.
I'm gonna message...
Oh my god, I can never have time to message the guy.
Be like, hey, you wanna lose all for one?
Pretty silly.
Pretty funny.
Oh yeah, I gotta fix the overlay.
Okay, let me fix it.
Oh my god, which one was it?
Was it this one?
Okay.
Well, I can't fix it yet.
Wait, did I fix my game though?
Is my game fixed yet?
My game is fixed, right?
I can't tell.
Yeah.
Yeah, it is.
Okay.
It is.
And then...
And then we lock that in.
And then we'll figure this out.
We'll figure this out the moment I...
Oh, maybe it's like here.
Okay.
Hawk.
Oh wait, hello.
Oh, I almost clicked that.
That would've been awkward.
I almost clicked it.
I saw Hawk and I was like, alright.
Oh.
Okay.
Do we have...
Do we have a Hawkeye player?
Oh, we do.
Okay.
Thank God.
Alright, back at it again.
I can tank.
Oh, we know who the tank player is.
I should've banned Hawkeye.
I should've fucking... I should've never listened.
That's a really good Ironman.
I...
I saw it.
Played against it.
Fucking...
Scary as hell.
As if, like, not my fucking duo.
Oh my God.
Yeah, I totally played against this fucking Ironman.
I got you, bro.
They'll never know.
I don't.
We'll switch later if you want, okay?
He does not...
That does not give me a lot of confidence when he says he doesn't Hawkeye.
Alright.
I'll have to walk up very slowly.
I'll walk up like this.
Alright.
I'm a little scared.
Oh my God.
Oh shit!
Where is that?
He's gonna rev.
Oh!
That's awkward.
Oh, here he goes.
What's going on?
I'm... What's going on?
What's...
Guys!
Guys, please!
Please!
He just...
He is just beating me up!
Oh my God!
Please just punch him!
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
How did he live for so long?
Alright.
He'll be fine, right?
He'll be so healthy.
Nice.
I will make sure you live forever!
Oh shit.
Who the fuck was that?
Who killed him?
Wait, what?
Oh my God, he's one!
Oh my God, I am...
Oh my God, he knows.
No!
Oh, I didn't ult.
That's good.
That's good!
That's not good.
What a combo!
Nice!
That guy had to be a Mercy player back then.
He has to be.
Okay, I gotta focus on my aim.
I'm like not even aiming anymore.
I'm just fucking shooting just for the sake of shooting.
Alright, where is Mac?
There you go.
I'll give him regen too.
Come on.
Stop!
Give me your head!
He has ult.
What the fuck?
Yeah, but why?
He's literally one.
Like, why?
No, kill him!
He's so low!
There you go.
We'll be fine.
Alright, cool.
Sorry, there was like a giant man trying to fist us.
Alright, there you go.
I'm okay.
He's not though.
Oh shit, I'm okay.
I'm okay still.
I am not okay!
Like, what?
I'm okay.
Again.
I'm still okay.
Okay, that guy's movement is actually insane though.
Is he gonna fucking powder through it?
Nice.
Alright, nice.
I'm on cart.
I'm on cart duty.
Vroom vroom.
Go, Mac, go!
Go!
I have sleep ready.
I don't have sleep ready.
No.
I'm asleep now.
I don't know if we're getting this.
There's...
There's a lot of stuff.
Oh my god.
He's mad though.
He's mad.
What?
No!
But we got it!
There's no more thing, actually.
Like, get the maximum pulse.
Alright, there you go.
My accuracy is better now.
I was a little worried.
I was like, oh no, it's hitting the 30s.
I'm starting to believe.
Guys, I'm starting to believe.
It'll be God of War soon.
It'll be God of... Please, trust me.
I never lied to you.
It'll be God of War soon.
We're so close.
Guys, we hit a couple of roadblocks along the way, but like, trust me, we're so there.
We're so there.
It'll be fine.
It'll be so fine.
We'll be there.
The moment we get there.
Oh my god.
I swear to god, it'll be so worth it, guys.
The payoff will be so worth it.
No, guys, I don't need to change the thumbnail.
Just think about the payoff, guys.
Oh my god.
Just think about the payoff.
The value.
Are they portaling?
No, they're not.
He's jumping.
Jump.
Oh my god, he's gonna fucking throw the Wolverine!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, they picked our healer, though.
No way, he's so low!
Um, yeah, but that's a lot.
I can't do anything about it.
Oh, good vibe, buddy.
Good vibe.
Don't worry, we'll be fine, right, Cloak?
We're gonna be so fine.
Oh my god, you're so healthy.
And Wolverine, that sounds so threatening.
Oh my god, he's coming in!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, we have to!
This is the only way!
Oh my god.
I'm alive somehow!
It was nice being alive for like one second, not gonna lie.
I like that I was alive for a second there.
That's pretty crazy.
He's like...
Oh.
Oh my god.
I slept him?
Okay.
Alright.
I don't know.
Where's that Iron Man?
I'm scared cause I don't...
Guys!
Oh my god!
I miss our Adam, he is...
I... I miss our Adam.
I miss having Adam, guys.
I...
I miss having an Adam, guys.
They're...
They're pushing fast.
We're really bad at defense, guys.
I think we're really bad at defense.
Why didn't we ban Hulk?!
Oh, you're so healthy.
You're so healthy.
You're...
Oh my god.
I'm so unlucky.
I saw that too.
Oh my god.
We all need heals, my guy.
I can't even damage boost.
Oh, he's so low!
Please get them, I...
Where is he?
Somebody slap him.
That's right.
Yeah!
No.
That's fine.
We fight, Hulk!
We fight!
Go, Hulk, go!
I'm coming back.
I don't wanna fight anymore.
I actually... I don't wanna fight anymore, Hulk.
I don't...
I don't wanna fight anymore, Hulk.
I...
Alright.
Cool.
What's going on?
Someone shoot him!
Shoot him!
This...
What?
Where's my Iron Man?
Like, what's just a fucking brawl?
I can barely keep up!
What's going on?
It's fine.
I killed their Mantis.
It's a fucking brawl right now!
Please.
Please get him.
Oh, fuck!
Wait, a fucking little rat!
You're such a rat.
You're actually such a fucking rat.
Oh my god, that Iron Man was such a fucking rat.
Holy shit.
He was a very smart rat though.
You know.
That's fine.
You're so much better.
You're so much better, Max.
Oh my...
Is my team okay?
Like, we're...
I don't think...
Oh my god, I didn't know!
I didn't know!
What the fuck happened?
Oh my god.
Shh.
Tension.
No.
Get rid of that Mantis!
That's right!
Fucking fuck that Mantis!
I'm coming back.
Oh!
I'm not... No, I can't!
The Iron Man's back!
Please!
I'm so... I'm not close to ult, guys.
I am absolutely not close to ult, guys.
I am not close to ult at all.
Go.
No!
Oh my god.
I was not close to ult.
I should've went Jeff!
Just to be fast, I should've went Jeff.
Oh my god.
This is fine.
Guys, this is fine.
This is doable.
This is okay.
Guys, we just got to believe.
Guys, it's all about believing.
Believe in ourselves.
We just got to believe.
We're so inspired!
I'll be fine.
Everything will be... Just believe, guys.
Just keep on believing.
Just keep on believing, everybody.
If you don't believe, I'll cry.
I'll cry.
No, guys.
Guys, we will have God of War.
I would never lie about God of War.
We will have God of War.
This is just a little detour.
A little detour to the God of War.
Just a tiny little detour.
Just a very tiny detour.
Yep.
A very small detour.
A very tiny detour.
Alright.
Alright, just...
Oh!
Very tiny detour.
Very...
Oh, this is bad.
This is very bad, actually.
This is starting to get bad now.
Alright.
Oh my God!
I don't live through that!
Okay, as long as you know, our other...
Okay.
Alright, I'm coming back.
Yeah!
It's fun!
I have to go jump to be fast!
Jump is the fastest support!
They got a tick!
Oh fuck, they got a tick!
They got a fucking tick!
It's fine.
A little tick won't hurt anybody.
It's when you have multiple ticks that it's a problem.
Yeah, but we already have a fucking rocket.
I can't...
There's nothing I can do.
I already have a rocket.
Alright.
Guys, we believe.
Guys, please.
Please believe, guys.
Please.
We got cursed for...
We got like times 10 cursed.
That every game I played was almost really fucked up.
Just believe.
Believe.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my god, 41% accuracy?
Let's fucking go.
I'm surprised, honestly.
I do not feel like I'm aiming very well right now.
I'm aiming for Luna, but for Mantis, I do not feel like I'm aiming really well for Mantis.
But hey, if it says 41%, I'll take it.
Alright.
Guys, don't stop believing.
If you stop believing, I'll...
It's like, if you stop clapping, I'll die.
I'm like a fairy.
You gotta keep on believing.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's like...
Alright.
Where is my Iron Man?
Nice.
Get the Groot.
I will fucking beat your ass, Groot!
Beat his ass!
There we go.
I told you to believe.
Alright.
I told you guys.
Everything will be okay.
So, we will get to God of War.
We will get to God of War.
I will get water.
I'll be right back, guys.
Guys, we're back where we started today.
We're back where we started today, guys.
We're back to God of War now.
I'm so sorry.
We're almost there.
Just two more games, everybody.
Just...
We're back to two more games.
Let's fucking go!
Two more wins.
Two more fucking wins.
I'm sup, but...
But what?
What?
Hiding my pick?
Because what?
What does that mean?
What the fuck does that mean?
Just...
Just pick your best support.
I can't flex.
Why are you hiding it?
Oh my God.
Alright, I'm banning Hawkeye.
Yeah, I'm down.
I'm willing to bet they ban Hawkeye and then I...
Oh shit.
I think they do Hawkeye, bro.
Honestly, I think it's fine.
Oh, come on.
Whoops.
Probability strikes again.
Oh my God, no.
Why did you tell me you were Raccoon One Trick?
I would have bet Mantis.
I would have...
Why would you hide it?
I would
have...
They wouldn't run Luna Mantis.
I'm okay.
Why would you hide it?
Oh my God.
The fact that he didn't hide it.
He hid it from me.
We could have... I would have banned Mantis.
I would have done it.
I would have fucking done it.
I'm not okay.
Why would they ban Raccoon?
Oh my God.
I would have...
I would have fucking banned Rocket Raccoon.
Who the fuck bans Rocket Raccoon?
No one would know you were a One Trick.
Oh my God.
There was so much damage.
Rocket was healing.
Okay, it's fine.
I died for the cause.
If they see the pink rocket, they think, what are they gonna think?
Oh my God.
That guy's a Rocket One Trick.
Who in their fucking right mind will think there's a Rocket...
will think that.
Oh my God.
That Strange is so low.
Goodbye.
Bye.
Whoa.
Oh my God.
This Mag is crazy.
Oh no.
No.
I'd just be like, if I see him on Raccoon, I'd just be like, he just wants to play Raccoon.
I would not think that he was a Rocket Raccoon One Trick.
That would never cross my fucking mind.
That would actually never cross my mind.
Alright.
Yoki is such a liar.
How am I lying?
Oh, it's just me.
Okay.
It's just me.
I just got I...
Oh, this is where I die.
Oh, this is actually where I die.
Wait, do we not have Wraiths?
That's fine.
We're at 99 anyway.
It was where I was gonna die, but that's alright.
It just hurt it a little bit.
Okay, that was a weirdo.
That's fine.
Sorry.
His movement was too good.
I...
Sorry, I had to like think a little bit.
I had to reset myself when I missed like three shots in a row.
I was just like, oh, that's not great at all.
That's actually not great.
That's three!
Oh my god, please.
Please.
I actually had to stand still and be like, alright, I gotta reboot my brain.
I think I saw Kratos somewhere in the background.
It's basically, I got a war level.
Oh, you think about it, chat.
If you think about it.
This is basically it.
Oh yeah, no, Carter fucking popped off.
I still can't believe Sylveon was like, I can't pick my character because I'm worried they'll target ban me because Doki Bird's a streamer.
Who in the fucking world would ever target ban Raccoon?
I like...
Who in the fucking world would ever do that?
I've never ever seen a Rocket Raccoon ban.
It's like the most worthless use of a ban I've ever seen if they ban a Rocket Raccoon.
This is God of War.
I like they tried a target ban and then they gave Mac a... Oh my God.
Jesus Christ.
I really need heals though.
But they gave Mac fucking hella like...
I'm capping point.
Stay on it.
I'm capping point too.
Okay!
You did not have to jump there.
Okay, that jump ball.
I hope I'm shooting.
Oh my God, I actually got him too.
What the fuck?
Let them come in.
I can't see them.
Where are they?
Oh.
Wait, they're not right side.
They're still here.
Oh shit!
Where?
That's fine.
Everything is fine.
Alright, nice.
We did it.
Oh my God, they have a Thor.
CC!
Guys!
I need to break the stair.
I got stuck.
Nice.
I did that.
Okay.
I leave.
I leave now.
Oh my God.
Are you guys okay?
Are you guys...
Are you guys safe?
Are you guys okay?
Yeah, everybody is okay.
Yeah!
Beat her up!
I believed in you in beating her up.
Oh!
That was...
Okay, that was pretty good.
That was a pretty good ult.
Also, who the fuck watches the YouTube stream for stream sniping?
It would make sense if I was on Twitch.
Oh my God.
I don't know.
If I tell them it's one more game...
I'm scared.
What he's gonna do?
Last time I told him...
He went storm.
That I needed one game.
Oh my God.
This is it.
Guys, this is it.
Guys, it's time to believe.
Everybody, it's time.
It's time to believe.
Believe.
It's fucking time.
We're there.
We're gonna be there.
Alright, that's fine.
I can play Mantis.
That's fine.
I'm very...
I don't care.
Winter Soldier.
They have three magic players?
Okay, I'm banning magic then.
Yeah, but then none of them can play magic.
Um...
Then what do we do?
But what about Hawkeye?
What about Hawkeye?
Magic is a bigger problem than...
Winter Soldier, I feel like.
Okay.
Do we have a Hawkeye player?
I don't think it's worth playing on offense on this map.
At the first player list.
Alright.
That's fine.
Wait, what the fuck?
It's bugging out.
Oh no, they're just fucking around.
Yeah, they're just fucking around.
I like...
Okay, it's bugging the fuck out.
Like, I don't like this.
Alright.
Oh my god.
My friend sent me this.
I'm so sorry.
My friend sent me this thing.
I need it.
Who made this edit?
Who the fuck made this edit?
I was sent...
I was sent this.
I'm so...
Alright.
Wait, is that a spider?
Okay, no.
Oh, thank god.
I'm so happy.
Oh wait, what the fuck?
Where is she?
Wait, what's my ping?
Like, am I not hitting any of these?
Okay, we should have bad magic.
We should have 100% bad magic.
What the fuck?
Where's my ping?
Where's my hit register here?
Oh, there we go.
Finally.
I was like, the fuck?
I should be hitting these.
Oh my god.
Her, like, portal shit is really good.
Okay.
Someone, please.
Get rid of...
There we go.
There we go, we did it.
We did it, everybody.
Raid boss down.
We fucking did it.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
That's good that I...
That's good that I, like, did that before he did all that other shit.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright.
Guys.
I'm a little scared.
I'm a little scared, guys.
This progression is not what I like.
Shoot the fucking water.
Alright.
I believe in them to kill the Starlord.
Oh, thank god.
Alright.
I'm locking.
Okay.
I actually have to lock in, though.
I locked in my aim.
My aim was, like, not great there.
Okay.
Come on.
I'm so locked in.
Oh my god.
Come back.
It's fine.
I'm okay.
It was worth beating a little bit.
That's fine.
That's so fine.
Okay.
I can't see him, but, like, I think I'm hitting him.
Like, I'm like, I think I'm hitting him.
Like, I can't see where it is, but it looks like I am.
Alright.
Okay.
Told you I'm locked in.
Told you.
I would never lie.
They're so... they're gonna run in.
They're...
Oh!
Goodbye.
I'm gonna leave.
I'm gonna...
Alright.
Oh, we have... we have Legendary.
Legendary.
Oh, and he's dead.
And he's dead.
That's fine.
We don't need him yet.
He'll exist for us soon.
I hear him above us.
Nice.
Oh, he has... he has... he has ult.
Oh!
Okay, that's fine.
Go do your thing.
Just shoot him.
That's fine.
We don't care about you.
Alright.
I'm going in back.
I'm going in.
We can kill him together.
Okay, I'm backing out a little bit.
Oh, I'm looking up.
Oh, I looked up.
I looked up.
Gamers looked up.
You can't blame that on me.
I actually did.
I did try so hard to look up.
It's not like I did not do the thing.
Alright, I...
don't have anything for that.
No!
Oh my god!
No, he still died.
Oh, nice!
But it didn't matter.
But we got the spoil of...
That's great.
Oh my god!
What?
No, he was so low.
He was so bad.
Mack, I swear to god.
Do not die.
Do not die on me.
Do not die on...
Oh, okay.
He died on me.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I don't know what's going on anymore.
There's so many things happening on my screen.
Oh my god.
There's like...
Everybody's just running around.
It's so cluttered on my screen.
Alright.
Everything was so cluttered.
It was actually so difficult to see.
Oh my god.
No!
We almost killed... Okay, it's fine.
We still have one more fight.
I threw there.
I shouldn't have fucking ran up just to try to slap him.
I just really wanted to slap him.
You don't understand.
Nice.
I don't know how I did that.
What?
He just sat there and...
Oh hey, that's me.
No!
I couldn't get out!
Not legendary!
I got legendary'd.
Oh my god.
Come on, come on, come on.
I'm almost here.
There we
go.
Oh my god.
No!
I can't do anything!
I'm scared about losing the cart!
I'm scared!
It's time!
I'm pulling it out!
Pulling it out!
I haven't played Jeff in fucking years.
Oh my god.
No fucking way!
Just a little shirk!
What do I do in that situation?
He literally just fucking...
Oh my god, okay.
Roz.
Just Roz.
Oh my god.
He literally...
He literally punted me up in the air!
How do I shift?
I was in the fucking air!
Oh my god.
He literally fucking punted me up in the air and I just had to live with it.
I tried.
I pressed shift.
It was too late.
He knew what he wanted to do.
Just sit there and watch.
I sat there and watched it happen.
It's okay.
I am alive.
And now we defend.
Guys, don't worry.
Technically...
There was Thor and Loki there.
Guys, I'm green just like Loki.
So technically...
Technically, I'm...
I'm playing God of War right now.
I heard that.
It's green just like Loki.
On the technicality, we're in God of War.
What the fuck?
Don't worry.
He'll be so healthy.
I'm a little scared.
Don't worry.
Okay,
I'm not gonna have enough leaves here.
Alright, cool.
It would be funny if I actually hit that.
The fucking random ass sleep up top there.
Please.
I'm trying to give us as many leaves as possible.
But it's so hard.
Oh my god.
Please.
I'm trying so hard.
No!
Guys, I don't know...
Okay, I'm cocooning.
Oh, not legendary.
Not legendary.
No, are you serious?
Okay, that's fine.
We're all here.
Alright.
You know what?
Just kill me.
I'm getting a hard focus.
I don't know how to live.
I'm just...
I fucking have 12 kills.
They all just fucking max 8.
It's okay.
I'm focusing.
I'm so fucking focused.
I'll just play.
I'll play.
I'll play safer.
I'll play very less aggressive.
If I stay with everybody else, I can't possibly die.
If I just stay here.
There's no way.
Serious?
Alright, nice.
Alright, guys, you guys gotta stop letting him fucking do that to you guys.
Gotta stop letting him just walk up to us and just start swinging like that.
I don't know.
Or I'll just do that, I guess.
I guess.
Or I could just do that.
That works too.
That also works.
Damage boost.
Here's regen.
Regen.
Okay, there's a lot.
There's actually a lot of stuff going on.
Like, what's going on?
Oh my god, he's won.
He's actually won.
Please.
How did we...
Oh my god, we lived.
I think I clutched that for us, honestly.
Oh my god.
I think I actually clutched that.
I don't know what the fuck I was doing, but we did it.
I slept her and then I somehow killed her.
It was just pure reflex at this point.
I'm just gaming at this point.
Oh, he's walking up.
Oh my god.
I don't have enough heals.
Please, I really need you guys to live.
Oh my god, he has all magic 100% has all...
And I'm scared.
Oh my god.
We still have to fight this for another minute?
I don't have headshots.
I'm not hitting headshots.
Please calm down.
Play this slower, please.
I'm not hitting any headshots.
Oh, it's fine.
I'm completely...
I'm fine.
No!
We didn't have the res.
Our guy died with res.
Oh my god, our guy died with res.
It's fine.
We're so healthy.
Oh no.
Oh, that's bad.
That's so bad.
I saw it like in the corner of my eye and I tried to run.
He like slowly flew up and I was just like oh man, I don't think I'm gonna make it.
I don't think...
I saw it in the corner of my eye and I knew...
I'm running away.
I'm running away after that.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Yes!
Magic's dead!
Evil has been defeated!
Oh my god.
Oh man.
I'm Groot.
I am Groot.
Last 30 seconds.
Adam, you better live.
Adam, you have to live.
Adam.
Oh my god.
Oh man.
No.
I'm going in.
Oh no.
No.
I lived for as long as...
Oh my god.
Adam and I are getting...
Adam and I are having the fucking roughest time right now.
Oh my god.
We're getting it.
Time's so hard.
Time's so hard in the back line.
I know.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
Adam and I are just getting hard time.
It's not a tie.
100 can only be one winner.
No.
Guys, it's possible.
You just gotta believe.
Just keep believing.
The Starlord and I...
We need help.
The Starlord and I are not having a good time in the back lines.
I don't even know what is killing me a lot.
I think it's the... Oh I think it's the Adam Warlock passive, right?
I have no idea how I'm dying so much.
I feel like...
Oh my god.
I don't think I'm like...
I don't know.
Maybe I'm mispositioning a lot.
I'll play more further back.
I could just be mispositioning.
Knowing me, it could be.
Yeah, that seems right.
I'm like a little worried that...
I'm trying to put two on cart.
Alright.
I don't really see them here.
I'm just shooting it for the sake of shooting stuff and hoping that I get something out of it.
Just kill her, kill her.
She has nothing.
Final 10 seconds.
Oh my god.
Come on, I'm so close to ult.
I have, I have, I have ult!
Nice!
They're making it for it.
Anyway.
What are you doing?
What are you doing over there just looking at us like that?
Huh?
What are you trying to do looking at us like that?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he got someone.
Oh, he's dead.
I'm gonna back
up a little bit.
Yes!
Oh my god!
I can't save that!
I actually can't save that!
I'm sorry!
Holy shit!
That guy got crushed by a fucking rock!
I'm just like, I'm sorry bro.
I...
My ult cannot...
My ult cannot fucking save that.
I know how much it would be amazing if it did but...
That shit is impossible.
That was a fucking rock.
That...
Okay.
Alright.
I'm fucking shooting.
Oh shit, what the fuck?
Oh shit!
I'm in, I'm in it, I'm in it.
Okay.
That's fucking right!
I am Groot!
Oh my god!
I looked at my chat.
He almost died.
I...
I turned around.
I wanna know what you guys thought when I did that.
Oh my god, it's literally like...
Come on.
Nope.
No dying for you guys.
I refuse to let you guys die.
Nope.
Get damage boost.
Oh my god.
We're okay.
We're so okay.
We're...
Where am I?
Where...
What's going on?
What's going on my screen?
Where am I?
Oh my god.
Don't jump everybody.
Stay on the cart.
If you jump, you die.
I am Groot.
Oh my god.
There's no way.
There's no way I can push through this.
I refuse to believe.
In one minute.
Oh my god.
Okay, but where we go until we lose?
We lose the next game.
Guys.
Okay, guys.
Think of it this way.
We go until we lose.
Guys.
We go until...
Max is like, it's time.
Guys.
We're on a hot win streak.
We can't end on a win streak.
Guys.
I promise you.
We will end when we lose.
Okay?
We haven't lost.
It's been like four to five games.
Guys, guys.
Four to five games.
Guys.
We gotta do it.
We gotta.
Oh my god.
What if we just hit eternity?
If we just never lost?
We hit this juicy win streak and we just never lose.
Guys.
Just think, guys.
I'm...
Just think.
I think our guy left.
I died.
Wait, I think this is a 4v4 now.
Wait a minute.
No, he's back.
He's back.
I was gonna be like, that would be very awkward if this is gonna be a 4v4 now.
5v5 now.
I think...
I think Groot's dead.
Yeah, Groot is not having it.
Oh my god, I almost killed him though.
Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Alright.
What?
Okay.
I'm not doing that again.
I learned.
I am Groot.
What the fuck?
He used a portal for...
Okay, I have a...
I'm Groot.
There we go.
Oh my god.
All these portals is fucking me up right now.
Okay.
That's fine.
That's not fine.
He's won.
I'm born again.
We did it.
We did it, guys.
We fucking...
We were here.
I came back and still no God of War.
Guys, okay.
Okay, now we go until we lose, guys.
Okay?
Guys.
We've done it.
Chat, is it over?
Oh my god.
We got it back.
Yo.
We can't end.
We have a win streak though, Mac.
Do we really?
You really wanna call it there?
Holy shit.
The Q was like instant.
Oh shit, it's hot sick.
Oh my god.
Guys, the moment we lose, we'll go to God of War, guys.
The moment we lose, God of War.
I swear.
I swear, the moment we lose, God of War.
No, it doesn't make me a liar.
We just can't end on a fucking...
You're doing last time QNT, congratulations.
Wait, me?
Who's he talking to?
Me?
There's like three streamers here.
Who is it?
There's three streamers here.
Alright.
I mean, they're gonna ban Hella, right?
They must ban Hella.
Right, guys?
Right?
There's no one?
Alright.
What if I just ban...
Alright, we both got Hella, that's fine.
No, no, no.
I swear to God.
I swear to God, guys.
I like how...
We're on a...
We're on a win streak, Hyde.
Don't regret it.
He's lying.
I lost my rank up game four hours ago with him on Storm.
Yeah, I know.
It's just kind of crazy how it works.
Guys, guys.
Can I get another healer?
Guys.
I guess I can swap to it if no one else wants to.
It's a very good tank.
Oh, thanks, man.
I like how our other...
I'm just gonna heal bot.
Oh, I like how our other tank swapped.
I like how our other tank swapped healer.
Oh my God.
That's already like off to a very good start, guys.
The fact that the other...
Oh my God.
I don't know, guys.
What do we do?
Oh my God.
How do we get out?
Oh, please.
I can't.
He's one.
Okay.
I'm zapping the fuck out of him.
Alright.
Okay.
I think...
I think I...
Alright.
Guys.
Did you really have to curse me again, guys?
Did you...
We have...
3 DPS that are not willing to swap to support.
We could have had double tank, guys.
Guys.
It could have been double tank, guys.
You know what?
Fuck that guy in particular.
Fuck him in particular, though.
Oh my God.
Fuck that one guy in particular.
He swapped to starlight.
I told you back!
Storm is shit!
But I don't want to go home.
I don't want to go home, though.
Guys, can you guys drop down to us?
Guys.
Guys, we can't.
I'm scared.
Alright.
I heard something.
Alright, yeah.
Fuck your platform in particular.
Guys, please.
Guys.
Come on, wouldn't it be funny if I just have like this most insane win streak and then we just end eternity on stream?
Like, that would be so insane.
Like, honestly.
That would be like the craziest shit ever.
Guys.
That would be so fucking crazy.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, I dropped.
I'm gonna kill Panther.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Sorry.
That's fine.
I thought he said me first.
No!
Okay, that's five.
That's fine, just beat him up.
So winnable, so winnable.
Come on, come on, come on.
Just live, just live, just live.
No!
Oh my God.
I thought he said...
Wait, didn't he say Luna first?
I thought you said Luna.
I was miscommunication.
I thought he said Luna first and I got so confused.
I was like, Luna first?
Okay.
It's usually Mantis.
Oh my God.
Why is Mantis always first?
Because you can use Mantis as an aggressor.
No, no, not yet.
Not yet.
Not yet, I'm still here.
I'm still here, guys.
Not yet.
Oh, he said target Luna first.
Oh!
I thought he said Luna first.
That's why I was like, oh, me?
Oh, big dude.
You gotta stop bringing that half in, man.
Yeah.
You gotta stop that.
Oh my God.
I got my ult at least.
Yippee.
Put it on him first.
Oh God.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Oh my God, where is everybody?
Oh my God, that's where everybody was.
I was like, where is everybody?
Okay, um...
Other than that, I... Oh my God, how many fucking ults were that?
Oh my God, that was... Where's our ults?
Where's...
Where was our ults for that?
Okay.
Alright, that's fine.
I don't need these staircases anyway.
Bro, that was like...
Please.
Alright.
Hey guys.
We just let Benny set up 50 mines on the point.
It was even down.
Your curse is weird.
She just died and respawned.
She just put it down.
It's not set up.
I'm still GM1.
Alright, alright.
I gotta play.
It gotta work now.
Jeez.
I promise.
I end on a loss.
Alright, before I...
Alright, guys.
Check Mac out, by the way.
Check...
Alright.
God.
They cursed my last game.
If you're still on...
Afterwards...
We...
After I finish...
We go again.
Alright.
Now that I got GM1 back, you can unban everybody.
I'm okay now.
My crazy arc is...
My Minhera arc is done.
But show him some love.
Show him some love.
I told you!
I told you I keep my promises.
Look, I'm still...
I'm GM1 now.
I'm back to GM1.
Alright.
Alright, let's see.
Wait, how do I...
What is it?
We'll see if I'm up.
Alright, let's see.
How do I gift subs again?
Technically, we didn't do it in two games.
So he gets...
He does not get all the cut.
How the fuck do you gift subs?
Holy shit.
I have not done this before.
I have not done...
Oh, there we go.
Gift.
Bonus subs.
Okay.
Alright.
He deserves it.
He fucking deserves it.
After everything I've been through.
Wait, what did he say?
He deserves it after...
Not a hundred though.
Not...
After...
Alright, not a hundred.
Not...
It was a lot longer.
Than two games.
Alright.
I should have given him 20.
Just because he fucking...
I should have just given 20 for the storm pick.
Every deductible...
I should have just done all the deductibles for all the storm picks he did.
Alright.
Alright, mods.
I feel a lot more... I feel better now.
So like...
You can unban everybody that got banned.
Like...
I'm okay now, guys.
I'm not...
Now that I got my rank back.
You guys can like...
You can unban all of them.
I don't know if they can actually.
I feel like I have freedom for my voice.
The great unbanning.
All my mods that made the list was like...
Wait a minute.
What do you mean unban?
We can do that?
There, see guys?
I told you.
I told you I'd be back.
I wouldn't lie.
This isn't clickbait.
What do you mean unban?
You can crumple up the naughty list now.
I don't remember.
Did I play with mouse and keyboard?
Or with a controller?
I don't know how many...
How many of the new mods...
Guys, we could've been eternity.
Guys, we could've...
Why curse me?
We could've been eternity.
Alright.
Alright, guys.
Did I play with mouse and keyboard?
Or controller?
I don't remember.
It's been a long time.
It's actually been a long time.
It's been too long.
Did I play with controller and keyboard?
Guys, which one?
I remember controller.
Is it...
It's been so long.
Was it actually a controller?
I don't remember.
I don't...
Guys, there has to be somebody that remembers.
Just pull up the VOD.
We can just pull up the VOD.
Guys, also I need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Alright, I'm back.
It was a controller?
Alright, give me a sec.
Let me get my controller then.
Oh my god.
What a fucking stream.
It was a journey.
It was truly a journey.
I can't believe we did it.
It just took...
I can't believe we fucking...
It just took me three hours.
No big deal.
You know, it's not a big deal.
Just three hours and forty minutes on my fucking life.
God.
Not that big of a deal, guys.
Not too bad.
Not that long if you think about it.
Where the fuck is my cable for this?
Oh no.
Oh no!
Guys, I need to get a cable real quick, guys.
Also, who the fuck did I mod?
Everything is up there.
That period was like a blackout period for me.
I don't even know half the things that happened there.
I'm not okay.
I'm grabbing my cable.
Okay.
Alright.
Like, how many did I...
It's like I just woke up.
Like...
I just woke up from a fucking trance there.
I'm like, what happened?
What happened?
Where are these new people in my chat?
Alright.
Okay.
Let's do this.
I don't remember how...
Okay, guys.
Now we're actually...
I told you.
I told you it wasn't alive.
Guys, I told you.
I told you, guys.
I told you we're in it.
Dad's coming back.
Guys.
Dad came back.
Like...
Alright.
What is my settings for...
Sorry.
Okay, I need to remember what my sound setting was.
Okay, 10.08.
Okay.
We have to redo all my settings for this.
Okay, 10.08.
There we go.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
It's been so long, Dad.
It's been...
My controller's not working, guys.
My controller's not working.
Wait a minute.
Why isn't my controller working?
Okay, maybe I need...
Wait a minute.
This isn't Marvel Rivals.
Maybe it's the PlayStation controller.
Is it the PlayStation controller?
Or is it the...
Let's see.
Okay, yeah, it was the PlayStation controller.
Alright.
What the fuck was I doing?
Are you sure I was playing on a controller?
Are you guys sure?
Feels weird.
No way.
Was I actually...
Where am I?
Oh, shit.
How do I play this game?
I remember I talked to the guy.
I have his head.
Okay.
Alright, so...
And then...
Really?
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm trying to remember.
I like to do that and then...
And then that.
And that's how I melee.
Alright, where do I go?
I took his head.
Alright.
Last time we were here, we took this guy's head.
Because we were going to bring him somewhere.
Now where the fuck do I go, boy?
Check my skills.
Do I have enough skills?
I'm tired.
I'm joking.
I'm joking, guys.
I'm...
We're gonna...
We're gonna do it.
Okay, magic combo.
Light arrows.
Oh, wait.
That's so cool.
Okay, let's just buy everything.
Fuck it.
Oh, wait.
What should I get, actually?
I just did 10 minutes.
I just booted up.
I was like, alright, that's enough God of War for today.
Alright, I'll see you guys next week.
I'll see you guys next week.
Alright, which one do I get?
Do I get...
Light potency.
We can use light arrows.
Increase weaken status.
Oh, why did I upgrade this?
This looked like it was worthless.
Is there anything I should get on here?
The betrayal.
You!
I miss Marble Rivals.
We could be playing...
Doki, we could be playing...
Marble Rivals right now.
We could be playing...
Marble Rivals.
Oh, shit!
Wait, that looks cool.
I want this.
Come on, Doki.
Just one more match.
You know you want to.
Oh, wait, I can get...
3 targets at once?
Oh my God.
I can run?
I don't feel like I run a lot.
What is this?
Heavy attack to...
Okay, you know what?
I don't know if I'm actually going to do it, but fuck it.
You know?
Maybe I'll accidentally do this.
When I button mash.
You know?
I'm just thinking like, oh, maybe accidentally I do it.
Which is fine by me.
Do I have a better one?
Oh, I do.
It's gold now.
Nice.
Alright, I'm gold now.
Oh my God, there he is.
There's his head.
Oh, what's this?
We're going to...
Neonon.
We go this way?
Alright, we go this way.
Alright.
No, wait, I came from here, didn't I?
Boy, where do I go, boy?
Boy!
Where do I go?
I'm fucking lost, boy.
Boy.
It has to be downstairs, right?
Yeah, he's looking downstairs, so he knows what's up.
Alright, this has to be it.
Boy!
It's over there.
Yeah, that's where she lives.
Oh, I remember the witch house!
That's when boy fucking asked me about, like, why he feels funny.
Oh!
What's that?
Oh, what?
Oh, to show it?
Oh, this is the gateway.
Can I go to the witch house?
You had a crush on the witch, don't you remember?
Look, I remember that part.
He was like, oh my God, I'll do anything for you.
And then the witch was like, I'm like a thousand plus years old, boy.
Can we move the God of War stream next week?
I have to play Marvel Rivals and I can't watch the stream.
Pretty please.
GoldenFoxy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
For the people who are like, I'm gonna fuck you up.
Wait, where is it?
It has to be here.
That's where she lives.
Eh?
Do I not have any gateways there?
Oh, there she is!
That's where she lives.
Okay, before I head there, I want to double check.
If there's anything else here.
Nope.
Alright, let's go, boy.
Let's go.
Time to head to your very first crush.
Hey!
Everyone has like their first crush.
Uh...
Get me there.
I can't get there?
Do I have to go from here?
Wait a minute.
How do I get there?
Boy!
Where did boy go?
Boy?
Oh!
Oh, I have to go to the...
From the center.
Okay.
Wait, this isn't Marvel Rivals.
That's bad.
It said I play.
Guys, please.
Oh!
Jump in.
Come on, boy.
You want to jump in, don't ya?
It's so inviting.
Oh my god, it's been 20 years.
His nephews?
Who are his nephews?
I thought like they have kids?
I just know that Loki's children he like fucked a lot of monsters.
Like he had the horse, the snake and like the... what is it?
Like Basically Satan?
I just know that Loki's kids...
Oh!
Alright.
In we go.
Oh no, no.
He got fucked.
Not the other way around.
Sorry.
Loki's definitely a bottom.
Oh, it was hell.
Oh my god.
Fucking Marvel Rivals brain rot right now.
I was like, silly you.
Hell yes.
Hell yes, they're sister.
But I forgot the original Norse mythology.
Hell yes, actually Loki's daughter.
Oh my god, are you gonna share?
Guys, I didn't eat lunch.
Guys, I...
Guys...
After this, I'm gonna get something to eat.
The nipples stay out.
Like, how is that protecting me?
Why would I protect my arse but not my fucking nipples?
Like, I can just...
It's literally like in the center.
I can shoot...
If I had a gun, I'd just...
Then why wear armor?
Why would anyone attack bear?
Oh no, it's at the center mass?
Alright.
Oh, I got a bow upgrade?
Where is it?
It just says waist armor.
Okay, what do I...
Okay, if I upgrade the boy, then like I don't have to ever increase arrow capacity.
Oh, we upgrade the bow so that I don't have to do anything.
And I guess I could upgrade...
Yeah, upgrade the boy so I don't have to work anymore.
I'm gonna live through my boy.
I'll live through you.
Low perk.
That's the way.
Yeah, 100% the boy will do everything for me.
That's why when I retire, he'll take care of me, right?
He's not gonna put me in a home.
Guys, even though it took me two months to come back to you, you won't put me in a home, boy.
I take care of... Look at me, I treat you so well.
Alright.
Door open.
Okay, there's the tree.
Does this take me to where I need to go?
I don't...
I don't remember if I have to go through the tree or... Oh, wrong way.
Alright.
Open Sesame.
Oh, Chad is dead?
Ever since we left Marble Rivals, it's never been the same.
Chad is still living in the Marble Rivals world.
They're still living in the goddamn past.
Alright, that should fix it.
It didn't fix it.
Sorry, it didn't fix it.
Man.
Okay.
And then...
Hello?
Where are you?
Oh, there you go.
That fixed it.
Alright, which way, guys?
I'm directionless right now.
Oh, maybe this way.
It has to be this way.
Alright, open Sesame.
How do I make the boy work again?
Where do I go, boy?
Where do we go?
How do I make the boy work?
He's gotta work for his stay.
He's gotta learn.
Oh, that way!
Okay.
I was like, what?
Where's door?
Oh.
Oh, what's over there?
Like, the rabbit and the hare existed in this world?
Oh, nice.
Good thing he's dead.
It's gotta work now.
Oh my god, is that Thor?
From Marvel Rivals?
Oh my god.
I told you, guys.
I told you it was Marvel Rivals.
I told you it was God of War.
If I'm not supposed to go there, where am I supposed to...
That has to be Thor.
Is there like a secret?
Oh my god, there was a secret.
A secret hole.
Toki, please.
We're in God of War now.
It's time to stop.
Alright, let's see.
So we go this way.
It's nice to have, like, my personal navigator.
I don't need to ask for directions.
Alright, here we go.
And we go this way.
Secret tunnel.
This is a very long secret tunnel.
It's been zero days since she last mentioned Marvel Rivals.
Oh, nice.
Alright.
Those Nord people really copying Marvel Rivals making Thor?
Oh my god.
I forgot.
How did you...
Boy, how did you...
How do we do this, boy?
Boy.
Boy, I don't remember.
Boy, what are the controls, boy?
Okay, not that.
Oh, yeah, that was it.
Alright.
Those were the controls.
Thank you, boy.
Thank god you're useful.
Good thing you're useful, boy.
Or you wouldn't be able to sleep in bed tonight.
You'll have to sleep on the floor.
I'm a good parent.
Bye.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
I'm a good parent.
What the fuck are you gonna do with the head?
What?
The fish?
We have fishies?
Alright.
That's fine.
Just gotta learn.
Oh, wait, nice.
Arrow.
I don't remember how to play this game!
Oh, fuck!
Oh my god, okay.
Oh, my axe!
Give me my axe!
I don't remember!
Oh, fuck!
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, I'm running!
I'm running!
That's fuck- oh, are you serious?
Oh my god, just fucking just shoot your arrows.
Just shoot your arrows.
I don't know what the other controls are.
That's fine.
Just keep shooting!
I'll just keep whaling on him!
That's right!
Just keep dancing!
Oh my god.
Oh, it's the wolf attack!
Nice.
Alright, I lost a lot of HP.
But that's how you're supposed to play the game, right?
Alright.
That's fine.
I lost a lot.
That's okay.
Let's put on a show!
God, shit.
Fuck.
Okay.
Oh my god, my fucking brain riots.
My brain riots terminal.
Guys, it's- It's terminal.
How do I- How do I open this?
Do I have it to open this?
Oh!
Just stabbed the head.
Nevermind.
I got a little confused, because there was a glowing thing to my right.
I can now read the language of Muspelheim?
Oh!
I can visit the Fire Realm.
Nice.
Thank you, it's been an incredible and fantastic year, hasn't it?
My birthday is on the 30th.
Can you close this year of mine by wishing me a happy birthday?
Glad you got your golden rivals.
You did right!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Delta!
Yeah!
Wait, how do I get up?
Oh, I just have to walk up.
Okay.
What's that?
That's fine.
I ain't no god.
I say as the deepest god of war.
Oh!
Where?
Who?
What are you looking at?
Oh, the turtle!
Do you think the pig is still alive?
Okay, is this a shortcut?
No.
What's this?
Oh, where do I put this?
Oh, right here!
Okay.
Now what do I do?
What the fuck do I do?
Oh, there you go.
Do your thing.
Boy, do your fucking thing, boy!
Boy!
This is not...
Oh, no.
It's a puzzle?
Oh my god, I just played for hours.
My brain is not ready for a puzzle.
My...
Oh, it's...
The hardest fucking puzzle of my fucking life.
Oh my god, I figured it out, guys.
Read, boy!
I'm illiterate.
That's going in the journal.
One of the hardest things I've ever done.
Oh my god, what a hard puzzle, guys.
Holy shit, that puzzle was so hard.
El Frigg!
Generous Frigg, who gave the world her brightest light.
Young Baldr, Gleaming God, Pride of the Iser, Odin's son and heir to Asgard.
Long may she protect him, long may he protect us.
Hail Baldr of the Golden!
Hail Frigg, beloved of all!
Hail Odin, all-father!
Seems like nobody who counted on the Iser is still around.
God, that was so difficult.
I'm glad we got through that together, guys.
What?
Wait, how did you get across?
Oh, circle.
Oh, there's some more kills here, which we'll need.
Oh, don't worry.
Don't worry.
That's fucking right.
Do your thing!
Do your thing, boy!
Earn your dinner!
That's right!
Earn it!
Okay, whoops.
I mean, it's fine.
He has like, he literally does not die.
He has to earn his dinner right now, guys.
Alright?
Alright, if you don't kill at least one boy, you're not eating dinner!
Okay, it's fine.
They're like, so weak anyway.
I'm such a good dad.
Huh.
Oh, shit!
Oh!
Okay.
Yay!
See, guys?
Dad of the year.
I came back from- with milk.
Nice, alright.
Yeah!
I did my job, guys!
I did it.
What's this?
I don't think I need to go here.
Alright, time to go to the house.
I came back with milk.
I did the bare minimum, chat.
I did the bare minimum.
That's better than all the other dads in the world.
That's better than like, 50% of the dads in the world.
What?
What's around the arrows?
What's wrong with the arrows?
Wait, now I don't have any arrows.
What's wrong with it?
It'd be easier if you explained it, though.
But they were green!
These arrows look so ugly!
He asked me to.
Yeah!
Oh my god, he gave us the green arrow.
He's like, this is DC.
We're a Marvel household.
He's like, how dare you bring DC into my house.
I mean, it's been like two months, so it should be fine, right?
Oh!
Oh my god, she like, fed him like, bugs and stuff.
Alright, time to boil my head.
Oh, you know how like, they boil heads to shrink them?
Like, you know those shrunken heads?
That's what they do.
Ah!
Good.
Oh!
Oh my god.
He likes that.
You know it.
Look at him.
Majesty?
Wait, isn't Freya like...
Yeah!
Isn't she like, the wife?
The mom?
I'm getting confused.
Yeah, isn't that the...
Yeah.
Yeah,
I was going to say, that's Odin's way.
I didn't...
Never trust gods.
Not even me, I'm a god too.
But you're a god, father.
That's why you should never trust gods.
Tyr's temple?
Wait, isn't Loki half giant though?
Yeah.
Where do I go?
Oh, it's right here.
Okay, I was going to say.
Where the fuck do I go?
Yeah.
He's like, half giant.
Oh, he's all...
Oh yeah, because he's like, adopted!
Adopted!
I forgot.
He's adopted.
Where's the yellow paint?
There's a yellow hand.
It's made just for me.
The yellow hand.
This is so long.
It's such a long elevator.
Alright, new destination.
Let me open this portal first.
Guys, I'm confusing my Marvel lore from actual Norse lore.
It's all blurring together right now.
I'm mixing the Marvel universe with the actual Norse lore.
Hahaha.
Yeah, but he dies.
He actually dies in the lore.
I forgot how.
He got killed by like, something dumb.
Everyone dies, Doki.
Yeah, but in the actual lore itself.
Sorry.
In the actual mythology of Baldur, I remember he was like invulnerable, but he dies a really pathetic death.
Alright.
Off we go to see the giants.
Snow giants.
Alright.
We're gonna see giant woman.
Oh.
Alright, cool.
Wait, there's a salamander.
There was a salamander.
Alright, get in here.
Hahaha.
Oh.
No!
Hahaha.
It was so close.
Alright, blow.
Run, seagulls.
We gotta eat tonight.
Hello, world serpent.
Hello.
I came back after four months.
I'm back now.
I swear I won't leave ever again.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, fuck him.
Hahaha.
Oh yeah, that's Loki's son.
Holy shit, is Loki okay?
Like...
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
Never been the same since the gay birth to that snake.
Oh.
Anybody have to push that up?
I don't think anybody will be okay after that.
Hello.
He can talk?
What's he saying?
What?
What is it?
Wait, okay.
Wait, he said like a lot of things, Mr. Head.
Mirror, he said like at least like 10 sentences and I don't get a translation?
Like...
He said something important to me.
Oh.
Okay, but where do we find the...
Oh, okay.
He knows where it is.
That's good.
Hahaha.
We're gonna have to give him a drink later.
What's that?
Oh yeah!
Boy, we are not exploring.
We gotta get the chisel, boy.
Oh boy, it's time.
How do I get down?
Oh, it's here.
Alright, boy.
This is not a field trip.
We're on a mission.
Okay, where's the hand?
Where's my yellow hand?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, wait.
We should be at...
Shouldn't we get the chisel?
And then...
And after we get to the chisel, then we get to...
Yoda.
Oh my god, you stupid bird.
God damn it.
God fucking damn it.
Okay, don't worry.
I got the next bird.
There's no way he'll know.
Alright.
Where do we go, boy?
Wait, what's that over there?
It's red.
Oh, is this more loot?
Oh, what's this?
What's this over there?
What am I doing?
Oh, this is extra...
This is extra HP?
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Let me get off the boat.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh, wait.
Tell me the lore.
You're supposed to drop me the exposition.
Oh.
Wait, where do I go from here?
What's this?
RIP.
Oh, no!
No, no, no.
I don't wanna... Oh, no.
That's fine.
Boy will do everything.
Okay, that's not fine.
That's fine.
What's he gonna do?
Climb up?
Okay, I didn't realize.
Oh, guys.
Guys.
They look very strong.
But, wait.
Wait, he can't go up.
Oh, shit!
Guys!
He can climb up!
It's fine.
Two of them can't climb up, right?
We're doing one by one.
That's fine.
Oh, shit!
I died!
I was like...
Wait, what's that?
I'm gonna put my hand to it, just like Silent Hill.
What could go wrong?
Oh, my God.
They can climb.
Who would've thought?
What's up in here?
Hello, guys.
Oh!
What is that?
He's not a dwarf.
Wait, how did he become a dragon?
Is that how...
How the fuck did he become a dragon?
What did he do?
What a glow-up.
That's not how evolution works.
How tiny become big.
And big become tiny.
No, that's not true.
Horses became big.
Hey, guys.
Are you bad people?
Oh, they're bad people.
Oh, I thought they were good people for some reason.
Alright, don't worry.
Okay.
Oh, fuck!
He's purple.
I don't know what to do when they're purple.
They fuck me up, guys.
Last time they were purple, they fuck me up.
I'm scared.
Okay.
The shield will eventually break, right?
You mean you're not ready?
What do you mean you're not ready?
What do you mean, boy?
Boy, be ready!
Boy, do your thing!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, boy, please.
Boy, please do your fuck thing, boy.
Okay, nice.
Wait, there's more?
Oh my god.
You think you can just throw that at me and everything will be okay?
Oh, where's the last guy?
Where's the last guy?
Did I kill him?
Oh, I killed him.
Nice.
Oh, it seems like there's still boss music.
Alright.
We gotta figure this out, guys.
Shields...
Shields are for pussies.
That's what Kratos would say.
Okay.
So that's one...
Oh, fuck!
Okay, sorry.
How do I activate this?
I fucking activate.
What the fuck?
Oh, break it?
That's right.
I don't need my...
I just fucking use my...
Who cares?
This damage is nothing!
I'm gonna take it all!
Yeah, how do you do it?
Yeah.
How did he become...
How the fuck did he become a dragon?
Did he get cursed or something?
Is this the other one?
Hey, guys!
Guys!
Oh, so that's where you went to!
Oh, fuck!
Guys!
Guys, I might need to use a shield.
Maybe you're right, guys.
Maybe a shield is it, guys.
Okay.
Don't worry!
Boy, aggro him, boy!
Boy, please do your thing, boy!
Not him!
Oh, god.
Oh, god!
Oh, invincibility!
Thank god for the invincibility!
Boy, please!
Do your thing, boy!
Oh, thank god he hit you!
Thank you!
Thank you for taking it!
Guys, we don't need a...
Blocking is for pussies!
That's right, it's all about the dodge!
Nevermind.
Never...
Where am I?
Do I have to do this again?
Oh, god, please don't tell me I have to...
Okay, no, I don't.
I don't.
I just have to do this part again.
I don't take it back.
Are you ser... Okay.
Alright, you little fucker.
I'm trying to free you right now.
Alright, get up here.
Alright.
Now that I know...
That he's very, very, very strong...
I'm gonna use my rage.
I'm gonna get very angry now.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
I'm gonna get so fucking angry.
I'm gonna get so angry.
That's right.
Oh, shit!
Guys.
Guys, I thought...
When I get angry...
That, like...
It'd be easier.
I thought...
Guys...
Guys, I don't think it's easier.
I...
Guys, this doesn't look easier.
Guys.
Oh, my God.
Give me the heals.
Oh, it was just that?
That's fine.
Don't worry, I believe in you, boy.
Wow!
Are you serious?
That aggro to my fucking body!
Oh, my God.
That aggro to my fucking body.
I dodged that.
I actually...
I swear I dodged it.
Oh, my God.
Only weaklings dodge...
Weakling use the shield.
Fine.
I'll do it.
That's fucking...
Get over here.
Oh, my God.
Rage!
I'm a fucking rager!
Okay.
My shield was up.
Guys.
My shield.
I saw you guys.
I said I can shield.
I...
Oh, my God.
Oh, it can't be blocked.
It's just like... Okay, guys.
Guys.
It's just like...
It's just like Dark Souls.
I forgot.
That's fucking right.
I'm fucking... I'm so mad.
Oh, my... What?
Oh, my God.
Okay, guys.
I'm not...
I'm not mad enough, guys.
I'm not clearly...
I'm clearly not mad enough, guys.
I'm clearly...
No, I can do this, guys.
We were so close from before.
Alright, we'll use our rage later.
We'll use the rage later.
Alright.
Come on, boy.
Wait, where did he go?
Are you serious?
You fucking tripped?
You fucking tripped, boy?
Ow!
Oh, God.
Yeah, that's right.
Hit the boy, not me.
Ah, shit!
It's time.
It's fucking time.
I'm fucking... I'm ready.
I'm fucking ready now.
I'm so ready.
Oh, my God.
I'm so fucking ready.
I'm not ready anymore.
I'm not...
Okay, this is not fair.
Wait, what?
What is he...
What?
What are you...
I had to...
I was like...
What is he doing?
What is he...
I had to hit the fucking...
Oh, my God.
Here we go again, boy.
We will learn.
We will fucking learn if it's the last thing I do.
If it's the last thing I...
Oh, my God.
He killed the wolf, though.
That's fine.
Oh, my God.
We gotta go.
Now.
What did he tell you when?
Wrong one.
Tell me when.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I got it first.
Thank God.
Oh, my God.
Thank fucking God.
Thank God.
Okay, kid.
Get up.
Are you, though?
Are you actually ready?
Oh, my God.
I missed it.
I freaked out.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I was freaking out.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
We're fine.
God, please.
Please.
There's so many things going on.
Oh, my God.
We fucking did it.
He's dead.
Oh, my God.
I'm just happy he's dead.
Just kill him.
Oh, holy shit.
Okay, these guys are easy, though.
Oh, my boy did it.
My boy.
My fucking boy.
Good job, boy.
What?
What an update.
Oh, the traveler.
Alright, you're not important to me.
Alright, so where should the last...
The last one should be on my left, then.
Right?
Okay, you guys are like...
You're not as scary.
After the shit I just went...
Oh, and then the last one is the easiest one of them all.
Alright.
Okay, this is good.
I'm just gonna do the fast way.
I thought, like, you know...
Me doing a heavier attack would mean it'll break faster, but I guess...
Fuck me, I guess.
I will freeze you!
Hello?
Oh!
Sorry!
For some reason, I don't know why I thought he was a friendly.
I don't know why I thought he was friendly.
Whoa!
I was like, hey, guys!
Isn't this... Oh, thanks, boy.
Wait, is he helping?
Is he helping?
Oh, he is.
Nice.
Okay, we're gonna get rid of the witch first.
Oh, okay!
Get rid of the witch.
Oh, my God!
There's too many things going on!
I fucking...
Okay, I'm using my rage art.
I'm... I'm gonna go get angry right now.
I'm gonna fucking... I'm gonna get angry!
That's fucking right!
That's right!
Get out of here!
Fucking meet me in the ring!
Meet me in the fucking ring!
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, I need you to stun her.
That's right, no more magic!
Magic's for pussies!
Oh, shit!
Oh, I'm sorry!
Oh, my God!
Boy, we need you to do all the work now.
Boy!
Boy, he's getting closer, boy!
Boy, he's getting...
Whoa!
Boy!
Boy, he's getting closer!
Boy, I need you to do everything!
Boy!
If I get hit, it's game over, boy!
Please, I need you to do everything!
Oh, no!
Why?
Why couldn't you do one simple job?
One simple job, boy!
You're a disappointment!
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God, boy!
I can't believe it!
No dinner for you tonight, boy!
No dinner tonight!
Are you serious?!
Oh, my God!
Okay.
Oh!
Oh, my God!
Wait, what?
I forgot my move!
What do you mean, not yet?
What do you mean?
What do you mean not yet, boy?
Oh, how do I use skills again?
Guys, you think I remember?
I don't!
It's actually been so long!
Oh, my God!
Oh, no!
This is not looking so good.
No!
Please, we're on the same team!
Oh, hey, nice.
Oh, no.
There's no heals.
Please, boy!
Please!
Why do you do so little?!
Boy!
No!
Oh, my God!
He does so little damage!
Why?
Why is your damage so low?
Where'd it go?
Oh, my God!
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna see if I can get rid of him first.
I'm gonna get rid of... Oh, my God!
Please!
Oh, my...
No!
Yes!
Just need to get rid of one first and then and then I'll start punching that again!
That's fucking great!
I'm trying my best to be father of the year!
No!
And...
Um... Um...
Um...
Guys, I...
Guys!
God!
Oh, my God!
Okay.
We can do this.
Guys.
We...
We can do this.
Guys.
Alright.
This...
Oh, my God!
Why am I so...
I don't...
Why am I so fucking weak?
Okay, just let me lie down on the floor.
Let me...
Let me lie down on the floor and just think about my fucking consequences.
Why did I have a kid?
Why did I have...
Why am I so fucking weak?
I thought...
Boy!
Why can't I kill the boy?
I'm gonna cheese this.
I'm gonna fucking cheese this.
I'm gonna...
Oh, my God!
This is...
You're so strong!
Why are you so strong?
Okay.
Okay, he fucking regen.
That's fine.
I can't.
I can't with you.
Why are you like this?
Why are you...
Oh, my God!
I hope you hit the boy!
Oh!
Shit!
No!
I actually got hit in the back of the fucking...
Alright, I'm gonna do ultimate cheese.
Abaco?
Did I spawn them in?
Oh, I didn't.
I didn't.
I'm underleveled?
Why am I here?
Alright, ultimate cheese.
I can't climb up.
Guys, I can't.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
I...
Wait.
Wait, what do you mean I can't climb up there?
Wait, you...
Oh, my God!
One-inch ball!
I'm so underleveled.
How do I get out of here?
I didn't know I'm in here.
I didn't know I was underleveled.
I just...
Okay, we can do this.
I will...
We can do this.
Where's the witch?
We gotta get to the witch.
We gotta kill the witch first.
Do your thing!
Oh, my God!
Not now, though.
Okay, maybe not this one.
Guys, I don't think we're gonna live through...
Guys, I don't...
Guys, we're...
They got me.
No.
No!
Where's the witch?
Okay.
I have a plan.
I have a plan, guys.
Okay, not like that, though.
But I have a plan.
I have a plan, guys.
I... Okay, we die here.
Alright.
No, no, no, no.
I have a plan for real.
Where's the blue arrow?
Okay.
Watch this.
I have a plan for real this time.
For real!
For real, guys!
No joke!
Oh, fuck!
No!
I am leaving.
How do I leave?
Okay, they...
They won.
They win.
Goodbye, I'll come back.
Boy, you gotta learn.
Boy, sometimes I'm not running away, boy.
Boy, I'm not running away.
We're coming back here, boy.
Boy, we're...
This is not running away.
We'll be back, boy.
I'm not a little bitch.
I'm just...
Sometimes, you just gotta come back another time.
It's called... Exactly.
It's a tactical retreat, little boy.
It's just... We're being tactical right now.
Okay?
Well, we will come back, okay, boy?
We'll definitely come back right here.
And then she never came back.
Sometimes, dad just gotta hit the gym a little extra.
You know?
Sometimes...
Dad's gotta spend a couple more hours at the gym, okay?
Wait, which way do I...
This way.
How do I get across this?
Oh, Pokka!
Thank you for the raid!
I really appreciate it.
I love you, buddy.
You've been playing God of War the last five hours.
Nice.
Hello?
Oh?
Who's that?
What?
Make the hole again?
Gross!
That's the love of his life, boy!
We literally burned your fucking mom!
And this is gross?
Oh yeah, we don't care.
What's this?
Is it even worth it?
Wasn't it for me, though?
Wait, why are you asking the child and not me?
I'm the adult here.
You think I'm just gonna let my kid do, like, some pointless task?
He listens to me.
I am the father.
Free bones!
Podoki, you'll get free bones!
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, shit!
Okay, you did not tell me about the goddamn fucking giant!
Okay, that's fine.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
There's more than just a giant here.
Okay.
Oh, shit!
Oh, infinity dodge!
There you go.
Nice.
Oh!
Get away!
Wait, how do I- Oh, R3!
Oh, shit, the finisher!
What do I do?
What am I doing?
Oh yeah, that's right.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
You try to flank me- Oh, sorry, boy.
Collateral damage.
It just had to be.
Nice.
Sorry, you might have got stomped a little bit.
Now.
Oh, not like that.
Wrong way.
Tell me when it shoots the fucking rock.
You can talk to mom again.
If we keep an eye out while we- Look if you wish, boy.
I will not be distracted by this fool's errand.
Bro, he looks like, like...
Might be from like, you know...
Hello.
You know, like those types of people.
You know, where they were like Jesus King from America, you know?
Alright, let's go.
Let's roll the boat away.
Hello.
Badadadadadum.
Badadadadadadum.
I love Book of Mormon.
It's such a good musical.
I love it.
Aren't they always fighting?
Oh shit, he killed his son.
They never actually die, except for Bulde.
But in his emotional state, soon found himself wandering Midgard, lost and alone.
Sadly, he caught the eye of the one person he didn't want to meet alone that night.
So far from home.
Thor.
And?
What happened next?
Thor?
You'll see.
Oh my god.
Must meet Thor?
To be fair, we already met Thor earlier today.
We met countless Thors.
Oh, is this Yodaham?
I thought I did travel there.
Caesar Mountain.
Is this Yodaham?
No.
Are we there?
From Marvel Rivals?
Alright.
Open the portal.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Where's that?
The fuck is this dead body in front of me?
Where is that?
Is that his hand?
Oh, that's his hand!
Alright.
Oh wait, I need to take my axe out.
What did I do?
Oh, he's like, he's green.
I can take him.
Oh boy, do your thing.
And then I'll do my...
ability.
That's right, spin!
And then ice!
And then do your thing again!
That's fucking right, what is he gonna do?
Fucking stab me?
Oh yeah, that's right.
You gotta do jack shit.
Alright, what did I see?
Wolvers.
Encounter more of these cursed werebeasts.
Oh, they're just like little werewolves.
Oh shit, there's more?!
I thought that was it!
Boy, I need you to do your shit.
Oh shit, boy!
Boy, please!
Boy!
Boy, you're not supposed to let him hit me, boy!
That's fine.
I don't need your help.
But what was the point of upgrading you if you don't help me?
Alright, nice.
Heavy attack.
Boop.
Alright, and then medium attack, and then heavy attack.
Nice.
We did it.
Oh shit.
Oops.
Wrong thing.
I saw blue and I was like, is that for me?
Is that for me?
Wait, is that another thing?
I thought that looked the same.
Oh, they look like wolves but they stand upright.
Oh, so they're like werewolves.
Oh, they're like Norse werewolves.
Norwegian werewolves.
Yoink mine now.
Shoot.
Yay!
What did I do with that?
Yeah.
That was useless.
What happened?
Oh wait, I can blow it up again.
I blow up again?
Wait, what?
Oh!
God, I'm so smart.
Alright, blow it up boy.
Good job.
That's right.
Now you can sleep on a bed tonight.
Is there another thing?
Oh, there was another one.
I'll move this way.
Oh my gosh, she's actually playing God of War.
What's that supposed to mean guys?
My thumbnail said God of War.
You thought I would lie about it guys?
I would never.
Me?
Lie about playing God of War?
I told you.
You guys didn't believe in me.
I open it like this?
Oh, I have to go the other way.
Okay.
Let me grab these real quick.
Alright, let's go downstairs.
Alright, boy.
Okay.
See?
That's magic for pussies.
Boy, you ain't no magic son of mine.
How do I get out of here?
The fuck?
Boy!
How?
Oh.
It's okay.
I don't need your help, boy.
I did it.
I have my trustees.
Trustees.
There's no way.
One of them has to be fake.
Alright, great robbing.
Yeah!
Taking you back to England.
Let's go.
Oh, rare chest armor.
That's good.
Boy, explain.
Explain to me.
Like it's Marvel.
I'm sorry.
Oh, there's Zed.
Guys, I'm illiterate.
That's why I make my boy read.
Why would I need to learn how to read when my boy can do it for me?
Alright, give me a sec.
Okay, I can't.
Alright, get over here.
Oh, okay.
Invulnerability dodge.
That was pretty sick, though.
You gotta admit.
I missed.
Guys, it's the effort, okay?
I think the effort I tried and that's all that matters.
Oh, wait, he's bigger.
That's fine.
I can take him on.
You know what?
Oh, shit!
Oh, okay.
I didn't think you would dodge that.
Oh my god, you are smart enough to dodge.
Oh, shit.
Come on, get over here.
Yeah, you think you can run?
That's fucking right.
2v1.
So fair.
Wait, that's another type?
Oh, it's like extra lore.
Alright, free robbing.
Yeah!
Guys, did we ever ban them?
Did my mods ban them?
Did we actually, guys, did we ban them?
I was thinking about it.
I was like, I wonder if they're free.
Wait, no!
Oh,
you guys!
You guys timed him up!
You guys!
Oh my god.
Weak.
You thought I would...
Oh my god, what?
Wait, okay, I had to aim, right?
Wait, you just...
Fucking blocked that.
Like a little bitch.
Why did you let him do that to me, boy?!
That's it, I'm fucking mad.
I'm fucking mad.
I don't care.
I'm just gonna...
I'm punching ice.
I'm gonna punch ice.
And it's doing nothing.
Alright.
That's cool.
Guys, the ice does nothing.
It doesn't...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm so weak, boy.
Boy.
I feel so weak.
Oh, boy!
Boy, I feel so weak, boy.
Oh, that's what it was for.
Oh!
I'm dumb.
I'm so dumb.
Oh my god.
I was like...
I was like, where is he dropping?
Oh my god.
I could've finished this a long time ago, guys.
I...
Alright, now I know.
Now I know.
I was like wondering where he was dropping.
Oh, I should've saved that, though.
I should've saved that.
Gotta open this first.
How do I activate the...
the ice giant?
Is it here?
That's here, right?
Oh, let me grab the stuff, then.
Yeah, where is the crystal?
Oh!
How did I activate it?
Where was I?
Where was I when I activated it?
Wait, what?
I don't remember where I was to activate this guy.
No, that's his face?
How do I activate it?
How the fuck did I start the thing?
Ah, fuck, who cares.
Huh?
What is that?
Oh, it's a boat.
Oh, I accidentally smacked him?
Oh my god!
When did I smack him?
I didn't even know I accidentally smacked the guy.
Whoops.
That's my bad, actually.
That's my bad.
That's my...
Okay.
That's fucking right.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
There we go.
No!
Ah, fuck, okay.
Oh my god.
Alright, this is gonna take a while.
This is gonna... I fumbled so much.
No!
Alright.
No way!
Fuck you!
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Why are they so...
Why are they so strong?
I'm gonna smack it until I... Okay.
Smack!
I figured it out.
Come on, look at me.
Look at me!
Oh!
Okay, not like that though.
I have a shield.
Guys.
No!
I just remembered I had a shield.
I just...
Okay.
That makes a lot more sense now.
Wait, what?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Give me.
There we go.
That's right!
That's fucking right!
Okay, guys.
Shields are not really for pussies, guys.
It's very situational, everybody.
Magic is for pussies.
I meant magic, guys.
Shields... Sometimes a real man's gotta use a shield sometimes.
It's not...
Sometimes a real man's gotta use a shield.
It can't all just be offensive.
We gotta be able to have a little bit of defense, guys.
Just a little bit.
There we go.
So easy.
Oh wait, what the fuck?
I have a rabbit on this guy.
There we go.
What?
Wait, there's still more?
Alright, there we go.
I did nothing.
Is that it?
No.
Wait, how do I...
Do that.
We got that.
Where's the other ones?
I feel like...
This is important too.
But I can't...
Oh wait, the tree!
The tree!
The sap!
Alright, let's go.
Let's do this.
That should work, right?
What?
Is that not what I had to do?
But it's red!
I have red!
It's red.
Okay, alright.
Fuck me, I guess I have to just spam it.
Alright.
My boy is just a little weak, guys.
Please don't judge him.
He's just a little weak.
Don't judge him.
He's still learning.
Wait, I'm trying to find the last one.
No, no, no.
It wasn't me.
It was my boy.
It wasn't me, guys.
But it's okay.
I am a generous father.
Read, boy!
What does it say?
Okay.
Wait, what?
Wait, but how do I get this?
Oh, boy!
No, boy!
Boom!
That should be it, right?
Did I get it?
It should be a W.
Oh, it's not a fucking W.
It's a...
Where?
What are you looking at?
What are you running at?
Where?
Okay.
Come on.
Oh!
No!
Yes!
That should be it!
That should be the right one!
Oh my god, I can't even do this anymore.
There we go.
It's a sideways W.
That should be it.
We did it.
I wasn't here.
Hello?
Whoa!
What did I get?
Oh, I get to increase damage.
Okay, we need that, actually.
It's actually really good for us.
Okay, now I'm a little...
He said he saw the crystal, but like...
I don't know where he saw it.
I came from...
Oh my god, where did I come from?
Wait a...
Oh, we're in.
I showed up here?
Yeah, yeah, I showed up here.
So then, it has to be at the head.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I should go this way then.
Alright.
Oh shit!
Oh my god, they're so fucking weird.
That's it.
Alright.
Oh my god!
So scared!
I'm so scared.
Oh my god.
It's like swatting fucking flies there.
Head of Thamur.
Okay.
We cannot go there.
What do I do?
Oh, I see the crystals behind me.
Is that the crystal?
Oh my god, let's go!
Let's go, teamwork!
That's right, I'm angry now.
I'm fucking...
Oh, I'm fucking angry.
That's fucking...
That's right!
I don't need therapy!
You are my punching bags!
It's free!
Who needs therapy when I can play video games?
Alright, nice.
Okay, it's not free though.
This game was expensive.
I didn't buy it.
Wait, did I buy it during season?
JK, I bought it in the steam sale!
It's cheaper than therapy!
Alright, nice.
That should be all of them.
Oh shit, there's more!
Oh fuck, there's a lot more!
Oh my god!
He used them as a fucking...
Holy shit!
Oh my god, that's fucking crazy.
He just used them as like a prop.
They're not even on the same team anymore.
Get over here.
Oh my god, that wasn't the one I wanted.
Oh my god, let's all just fucking...
Let's all just brawl.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Fuck it, let's brawl.
Let's fucking brawl!
Let's fucking go!
Oh my god, I'm stuck in a corner.
Guys, I'm...
I'm... I'm stuck in a corner.
Let me... Let me go!
Please...
I can't... Where am I?
Where?
That's fine.
Oh yeah?
There's a lot of things on my right.
There's so many things.
Okay.
I'm just pressing buttons.
And it's working.
And it's fucking working.
That's right.
Nice.
That should be everybody.
That's right.
Brain damage!
Woo!
Oh, that's more than just a brain.
That's just damage.
You think so?
Oh.
Yep, definitely I did.
Nice.
Easy.
Can I...
Oh, the ogre.
Where?
Oh, there he is!
Wait, how did he get here?
Alright.
Can I actually not go back?
Oh, I can!
Alright, before we do it...
Apparently, I missed a crystal.
I missed a... Oh, there it is!
Oh, I see it!
It's right over there!
That's where it was.
What do I do with a crystal, though?
Boop!
Oh!
Tree.
Alright.
Alright, boy.
Do your thing.
Boy, please.
Nice.
Yippee!
How do I... Okay.
Where do I put it?
Where's the thing?
Do your thing, boy!
Do the one thing that you're good for.
I don't know where I put this.
Oh, it's over here.
Okay.
What does it do?
What do I get out of it?
Boop!
Boy.
Oh, god fucking...
Isn't this basically a fucking...
I'm just fighting?
Oh, it's loot!
Oh, thank god!
Okay, you see... Oh, thank god.
Okay, I thought it was... I thought it was the fight.
Last time I stuck my hand through a hole, I died.
So, I was like...
I knew I died again.
I'm like, oh, thank god, it's different.
Now, it definitely keeps sticking my hands through holes.
Alright, up we go.
Alright.
Oh, you just watched?
Yeah.
How do you do it?
You mean use magic?
Oh?
Okay.
My boy does not use magic!
He is a man!
Nipples out for men.
Oh, man.
Oh, shit.
It looks like he's almost gonna cut himself.
For real.
Hahaha.
Oh, he's upgrading my axe again.
Wait, did he do it?
Oh, that was easy.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Wow.
See, boy?
This is why we don't use magic.
That was pathetic, boy.
Alright, guys.
We're gonna call it here, everybody.
We're gonna call it here, guys.
How do I save my game?
Wait, what?
What do you mean?
What do you mean you're gonna call it here?
Alright, guys.
We did it.
Yeah, we did five hours of God of War, everybody.
We fucking did it, guys.
I'm so proud of us.
We made so much progress.
We played the game!
Oh, man.
I'm so tired.
I'm gonna take a nap right after.
I know it's so boring.
Oh, yeah.
I got mod people.
It was two people, right?
I'm sorry, bro.
You've had your fun.
You've had...
Wait, did the other mod fucking left?
Where are you?
Oh, no.
Wait, is the other mod still here?
Wait.
I need them to chat so I can remove their mod.
Oh, no.
They left.
I need them.
When the chat history is back up, I'll remove their mod.
I need them to chat.
As long as they don't have Silent in their name, I know they're not mod.
That's how I do it.
If they don't have Silent in their name, they're not a mod.
What a crazy day.
Oh, I told you.
I didn't lie.
I did came back with the milk.
I told you we were gonna do God of War, guys.
I told you, chat.
I didn't lie about it.
We did play God of War.
Anyway, guys.
Thank you, everybody, for...
for coming.
I had a great time today.
I'm glad we're finally back at God of War.
After four months, we're finally back playing God of War.
It was...
I think I blanked out in the first three hours.
I blanked out in the first three hours of that stream.
So I'm pretty sure we made a lot of progress in God of War.
Because that was five hours of just playing God of War.
So...
I was perfectly mentally okay throughout all those five hours.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed.
Because...
Oh, there you go.
You talked.
Okay.
Mod gone.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
If you stayed up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!